Okay, everybody!
Hello!
Hello, hello!
This is Uto and this is Jero.
I'm meeting them for the first time.
Nice to meet you guys!
Nice to meet you!
My new friends!
Yeah!
This is like...
How many times are Ditto and I gonna meet again?
Yeah, this is my first time meeting you, Ditto.
Yeah, this is my first time meeting you, Ditto and you,
though.
Hello, welcome to Apex Rank.
We are the girl press squad.
All of us are like, Prey.
Right, Uto, you're Prey, right?
Uto, you Prey player, right?
Yeah.
Yeah,
Uto is a pro player.
She is actually the best player out of the three of us.
She got like rank one in season seven.
Yeah, Uto?
Yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, yeah, she was ranked one!
The pro player!
Yeah, so she carry us, right, Uto?
Uto carry?
Yes.
Yeah, Uto carry.
Yeah, please, please carry me too.
Yeah, carry us.
Carry Ditto and I get 20, 20, 20 kills 4k.
Okay, okay, okay, okay Yeah, I believe Yeah, yeah, guys,
it's good Okay, I'll die so I can watch you, though Okay,
okay Come on, come on Come on Let's go, let's go Ditto has
not slept a lot Actually, I just I just woke up She just
woke up She went to bed at 4 in the morning.
Nice to meet you guys.
Also, how long are we gonna play for?
As long as Uto wants.
Oh, maybe 10 hours, I think.
Wait!
Okay, wait.
Maybe 10 hours is not enough.
Yeah, you're right.
Maybe 12 hours?
Two streams.
Part 2.
Yeah, maybe two streams.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We should put another waiting room.
Yeah, do you like my tracker?
Oh,
your pet bash!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I have- I- I know I have a pet badge now.
Hey, here we go.
Where were we landing, though?
I woke up.
Don't worry, I- I can't- coffee
Like someone in my chat was like why is she playing seer
because seer is meta Yeah, his yeah seer Seer is uh, you
know how original seer was really broken They made they re
they changed it back.
So now he's like the original original seer.
One team.
Okay.
All right.
No, no, no.
Okay.
I'm gonna kill.
One down.
Fuck, I fucked the gap.
He's stunned, he's stunned!
He's alone!
No, he's not!
Wait, under?
Under two!
On me, on me!
I'll do it!
Can't do it!
I cracked him?
Two!
One or two, one or two!
I got him!
Knock!
Nicey, easy!
But don't carry!
Oh, they are masters!
Yes!
They're masters, by the way.
I told you we're better!
Because we're Pread.
We are all Pread.
Yeah, we're all Pread.
We're better than Master Player.
Let's go.
I'm so lucky I got Ward.
Yeah, I got PK.
So Soundcheck guy, how's the volume?
How's the volume, by the way, for all of us?
Look at that.
How do you follow?
Yeah, like sound.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is our sound okay, guys?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Nice.
Yeah, yeah, we can.
I'm gonna go with them.
I'm gonna go.
Okay, okay, you go, you go, you go.
What the fuck?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Back, back, back, back.
Down, down, down, down, down, down.
Down, down.
Nice!
Uto!
Three kill!
Three kill, Uto!
Nice, Uto!
Yeah!
My same...
My brutal!
Pro player!
Yes?
Oh yeah, that's your so...
What the fuck?
How do they have so much loot?
They have so much loot.
What the hell?
Yeah, why?
i have like nothing here yeah me too me too all right oh r9
nice one nice oh apparently r9 is not r e r yeah r e is so
good now really yeah because um because it's harder to get
armor so r e hammer point plus digi so everyone r e 45 and
uh did uh and hammer point is so strong digital um um did
you say yeah because because uh digi is now on pistol oh
yeah yeah yeah so no no smg so it's like i see i see do i
have anybody here okay i leave you guys if i die it's utah's
fault to you don't let me die don't wait i should scan to
you i need to sell me sell here yes oh oh where i heard a
hemlock hemlock thank you yeah hemlock where hemlock you
want hemlock or you hear hemlock no i i will play hemlock oh
okay i have hemlock like now nice i hear i hear 30 30 is
still strong uh 30 30 okay yeah 30 30 hemlock uh flatline
flatline yeah flatline strong uh and then short range is
like re45 now and vault mid-range is always strong though My
enemies can't?
Okay,
okay, okay.
Oh, I missed.
I know.
What the?
I see.
Oh, hey, are you?
Oh, on me?
I'm here?
Oh shit.
It's like it's her skull.
Behind this?
Flash, flash, flash.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
I must kick one.
I'm coming over here.
Oh no!
I'm dead.
Oh shit.
Oh.
Holly.
Can't do it.
He's the last.
He's the chair.
Oh no.
My shoe is broken.
My shoe is gonna bulge.
Okay.
No!
Pizza!
He shot me through.
I want to armor myself.
The prowler is so good.
Yeah, the power is broken.
No, you got you got prowler.
Okay, I should have queued.
I should have queued.
If I got pinged, ping.
Oh my god.
I mean, we're probably at warming up.
Yeah, warm up, warm up, warm up.
Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
Warm up until win.
We're not bad.
It was ping.
Okay, look.
Uto is playing with 300 ping.
Zeno is playing with 300 ping.
And I'm playing with 400 ping.
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're all playing with...
really bad ping.
Just this one.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
Champion, champion, next game.
Yes, sir.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, like, the number you see right now, that's not true.
I'm playing with 400 ping.
I'm, I'm playing with 200 ping.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But we're so good.
Even when we have high ping, ping we're so good yes yeah Uto
she's a pro player and she plays with 300 ping every day
yeah and she joined the stream every week I saw it yeah yeah
you know right now she's not playing with her monitor on
turn on your monitor turn on your screen She plays with only
sound only sound Yeah, yeah Big ears Yeah, only ears She's
so good Use your hands too, don't use your feet okay Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah Yeah, play with your hands though We need
to learn I know you're really
That's why she's a pro Oh
Okay, okay, okay now screen is on hands on the on the mouse
Where?
Okay Okay Hmm
I don't think I see I don't see anybody I think I see one
one team in countdown I think oh countdown okay That's fine.
Uto is gonna kill them for us.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Go to countdown, Uto.
Countdown?
Yeah.
Kill them all.
We loot.
You kill.
Okay, I got the power.
I got power.
Where are enemy?
Oh, countdown.
I'll break.
Yeah.
Let us go there.
Okay, okay, okay, yeah, you go now and then we loot.
Okay, okay, okay Go I believe in you You're so strong Don't
be white armor It'll feel easy So easy Yeah, yeah I'm going,
I'm going, sure What you're going?
Okay, I'm looting Come, come, come here This is important
Fighting for fighting.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
You're pro and Fred.
You don't need me Oh, yeah, we don't need you.
We don't need you.
Yeah, one pro player can kill three people
Why am I here?
Oh, right here, right here, right here Right, right, right,
right, right, right here.
Oh, she!
Okay.
Where?
This is a dead body?
Okay, on ping, on ping, on ping.
I'm bad, I'm bad.
Oh, I'm good.
Oh, okay.
On top, okay.
Maybe the last one?
I'm not sure.
I'm looking.
Okay, I don't see anybody in the scan.
Oh, here, here.
The flag.
Almost kicked.
I'm running.
I'm late.
Come over.
Come, come, come.
Inside, inside, inside, inside.
Come over.
Right side, right side.
Where is he?
Did he run?
Here, yes.
Okay, I'm gonna loot.
You guys will be fine.
Okay, we'll be fine.
Okay.
You'll be fine.
You'll need me.
You can kill them.
Loot is important.
Oh yeah.
Oh, look at all this loot.
Where?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Jesus.
Where are you?
Hey.
Are you still fighting?
Where?
Wait, there's... What?
Oh no, you killed them?
What?
No, I thirsted.
No, no, no, no.
I thirst.
Oh, okay, okay.
No one's dead.
Oh, I can't see.
Oh, guys, we'll be fine.
Okay, he's lucky.
He's lucky.
It's okay.
We kill him again.
Yeah.
You guys want to go...
Let them rest and we kill them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let them rest.
We won't get KP, but...
them you guys want to yeah we let's go here well okay um i'm
gonna scan the lane hey oh hey what you don't forget to um
yeah yeah yeah i'll go pick it up okay okay don't worry
let's upgrade our my army Yay!
Oh, upgrade.
My too.
Backpack?
I need a backpack.
Wait, what do you... Oh, yeah, no backpack.
Okay.
No backpack.
Wait, wait, no, let's start it.
Oh, nice.
Wait, can I... You're already scanning, right?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, you did.
Alright, let's go get vault.
Wait, oh, there's people here.
Let's go!
Wait, wait, get vault first.
Vault.
Okay.
Yeah, because I have key.
I want better stuff.
I have no attack.
I want hammer point.
I think they're fighting at staging.
Yeah, they are.
Okay, okay, vault, vault, vault.
Vault, vault, vault.
Open the vault.
Opening the vault.
Open.
Ooh!
Wow, wow, wow.
What is this?
I got everything.
Nice.
Wow, wow.
Wait, is this hammer point?
Oh, it's skull pierced you.
Let's go kill.
Oh, wait, what?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Behind, behind, behind, behind.
Look, look, look.
Behind us, behind us.
Behind us.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, let's see.
Okay, are you still flying?
I see, they're like this way.
It's so close, so close to us.
Yeah, yeah, there's a split, split up.
Oh, whoa.
Oh, my God.
Oh, careful.
I'm sorry Behind you behind you.
Oh fuck okay.
Oh no I'm so fucked.
I'm stunned.
I'm dead.
Don't oh I got stunned
Okay, all right All right, did I turn on your monitor?
i just did say say hi did you turn on your monitor okay okay
i turned on my monitor okay okay okay all right don't worry
i'll turn on my monitor too i'll turn it okay i'm lady i'm
lady yeah yeah don't worry don't worry all monitors turned
on don't worry no more no more listening just now we see
okay do you think um bangalore is good oh bangalore is good
i heard bangalore and horizon is really good horizon really
yeah okay i i play horizon bangalore horizon sierra
bloodhound i heard we're really good because like um i'm a
bloodhound because like uh his scans are better i don't i
don't remember his kit but like okay what is this kit oh
yeah the cool down and stuff gain and then the gain 25 hp
per knock oh revenant is good too revenant crypto is good
too yeah okay with me seer is good everyone plays seer now
Oh Are you prayed?
No, no, no, you.
Oh, no, I know, I know I meant my chat my chat my chat was
like seer is not good
I think seer is good on the the earth is really weak his
scan is better now.
Oh really his scan.
Yeah, because like it's longer Oh I say say say okay I will
smoke and you guys get and we win
One team oh, no No team no team no team no team
Come on, come on, come on.
I want I want power power.
I probably got power too Wow, that's nice I like how we're
on this same building oh wait is there a team with us um i
see no one no one okay i'm gonna look is there anyone here
really no no i mean any is there okay i'm going out
yes all you guys and one team on geyser one team on geyser
okay my i'll get the moby yeah two four two four i'll get
that Uh...
Let's see...
We're sure...
I haven't found a single hammerpoint.
Is hammerpoint crafter?
No, wait, no, it's bats.
There's no more crafter.
I forgot.
It's pretty hard to find.
Yeah, I haven't found a single hammerpoint.
I will be one if I found one.
Uh...
There's like zero attachments on Proudly.
I need...
Let's see.
Okay, I'm gonna go grab that one.
Oh, we should do...
Wait, is that ring?
Consulate.
Oh, wait, yeah, never mind.
That's...
Nevermind, that's map consulate.
Where are we?
Where do we... wait, who's IGL?
Uto, IGL.
Me?
Yeah.
You're pro!
Yeah!
Where?
Kill.
Kill who?
Who do we kill?
Where?
Kill enemy.
And kill the key force.
Kill the key force.
Where enemy?
Oh, here, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Stacks, stacks, stacks.
Oh, okay, okay.
Enemy, enemy, enemy, enemy.
Okay, okay.
Kill, kill, kill, kill, kill.
Kill, kill, kill.
Okay, okay.
Alright, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Ucto goes first because Ucto kill.
Uh, Uto's strongest.
First Blood.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm not sure if they'll finish.
I didn't hear anything.
I hear, I hear, here.
They're still fighting.
Oh, okay.
Where the fuck?
How am I not hearing this?
Oh my gosh, I need to turn on my ears.
Hey, use your headphones.
Sorry, sorry, I have my headphones off.
Sorry.
Let me put it on right now.
Okay, okay.
Alright, headphones on.
Headphones on.
Where?
No heartbeat.
Big mod.
Oh, Big mod?
Okay.
They might have better armor.
Maybe.
You guys...
I think you guys can scan.
Maybe.
I'm looking.
I'll have to get closer.
Maybe inside?
Maybe?
Inside?
Yeah, I think...
Our armor's pretty bad, too.
I'm gonna...
I can't scan this.
I'm too far.
Yes.
Let me shake.
Don't go.
No heartbeat.
No?
No.
Ditto!
You liar!
Oh, yeah.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, what?
Oh, so far.
Oh, Ditto, you liar.
One guy cracked.
You liar.
I'm lying.
You're lying.
Rotate!
Yeah.
Rotate.
This is why Uto's IGL.
Okay, Uto, Uto!
All this!
Wait, I think...
Uto?
In ring!
Go in ring!
Oh, hey, jump tower!
They're coming, they're coming!
Oh, jump tower!
Jump tower.
Yeah.
Oh, they flat.
Wait, wait, one!
Oh, they left, yeah.
Yeah, I will chase them.
Okay.
I guess I'll jump tower.
I mean, they are...
I'm so far Where are they?
I'm so far They're like They flew over this way Oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah What's wrong with your ears
Why is your...
They're here They're here I ping them?
Okay?
They're to my left Okay?
Cure them
All right, left side, they're...
Oh yeah, yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, they're coming to us, maybe?
Are they?
Um, they get inside?
Inside?
Oh, so they'll be right here then, yeah.
They have...
They have stairs?
I don't know.
I don't know, do they?
Yeah.
Ditto, put your headphones on It's science, science, science
No No, no heartbeat I heard something Where?
There's nothing No Where?
No heartbeat No, no, no enemy No enemy The teleport!
They left, right?
Who's over here?
I've done that.
I think they went.
Oh.
The wool was inside!
This is what, this is why Uto's IGL.
Uto!
IGL plays play games.
Okay, okay.
Go, go, go, go, go!
Okay.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, ring.
Where?
The toe's crazy.
Me?
The toe is crazy right now.
Take your meds.
What are we gonna do?
Go kill.
Go kill?
Okay, okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have a...
I have a tower.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I wait, I wait, I wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh shit!
One down, one down!
Nice one, nice!
Okay.
One keg, one keg, one keg!
Okay, okay, okay.
Is this yours?
Inside, inside, inside, inside, inside.
Oh, inside?
Okay, is this yours?
This is my urge, yeah, my urge.
Yeah, yeah, okay.
I'm going up then.
I thirst?
Thirsted?
Okay, nice.
Here, this way.
This side?
Yeah.
I think they run.
Oh.
Eh, enemy.
Look.
Oh, it's so long.
Left, left, left, left, left.
In front of me.
Oh my god, they- They're running!
Scared!
Kill him!
Up!
Up, enemy!
Up, up, enemy!
Okay.
Where?
Get here.
He run, I think?
Wait.
Oh, heartbeat?
Heartbeat here, here, here, here, here, in here, in here.
Scan, scan.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's not a spot.
Yeah, new team.
New team, new team.
Okay, okay, yeah, yeah.
Oh wait, okay, we have to go.
Yeah, we can go back, go back, go back.
Go back, go back, go back.
I don't want to fight in ring.
I hate fighting in ring.
Okay, me too.
Oh, the lever is so fast.
I know.
That's so fast.
Rev is strong now.
Does he have good loot?
Where did you kill him?
Oh, there he is.
Ooh.
Yummy.
Much.
I took everything.
Look at that.
We got it.
Uto Archio.
Uto kill.
Ditto.
What happened, Ditto?
I was smart.
No.
They shot me.
I was going to die.
Don't die.
I'm still alive.
Okay, this is why Uto is the pro player.
And we are just prayed.
Yeah, she not one for us.
Yeah, yeah.
We're just prayed.
She pro.
This is how she got rank one in season seven.
Oh, Rez?
Oh.
Here, Rez.
Rez?
Okay.
One team?
Yeah.
Oh, maybe more than one.
Maybe more.
Yeah.
More than one.
Let me check.
No heartbeat?
Anyone there?
No.
No heartbeat?
Okay.
So they're gonna come from, right?
We could meet up.
Okay.
We can meet up here.
What the...
Oh!
That left, that left.
I'm dying to the room.
On me, on me?
Okay.
Oh, enemy.
Heartbeat, heartbeat.
Okay.
Dokey, dokey, dokey.
Heartbeat.
Dokey, dokey.
To my right, to my right.
I hear it.
Yeah, yeah.
Two, two, two, two.
Two, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
He's stunned.
Yeah.
Bloodhound low.
Okay.
Got him?
Nice.
Where's your teammate?
I'm looking for heartbeat.
No heartbeat.
They left.
die to the link oh my god where's your friend he's not
family i think maybe he's like here somewhere like they walk
around okay i think okay i i get up yeah i think he they ran
around wow i would never leave you guys like where should we
go where should we go now i want to see find the Knock guy.
Okay!
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
Kill!
Oh, good.
Nice.
See?
Good idea.
Nice idea.
I will shut my mouth out.
I will shut my mouth.
Enemy.
Oh!
Help me.
We're coming over, we're coming, coming, we're coming.
Oh wait, four!
Wait, a lot, a lot.
Here, here!
Almost!
Miloš, here!
Oh my god.
Wait, red armor!
Holy splash, splash, splash.
My aim, that, that, my aim was pretty bad there.
Inside, inside.
Wait, wait, wait!
Behind you, behind you, behind you.
Oh my god, okay, okay.
Oh yeah, let's go for this.
Wait, wait, wait!
What?
Nice,
nice.
I'm going 2x.
Can you call me?
Wait, that's Digi.
That's Digi.
Oh!
We're so fucked.
We're so fucked?
I'm gonna... I'm going to...
Wait, this is Ring 4!
Oh shit!
Okay, this is scary.
Yeah!
Wait, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
Okay.
Maybe you can revive Uto.
Yeah, yeah, Uto, can you crawl to me?
Uto, can you crawl?
Yeah, yeah, keep crawling, keep crawling.
And you can revive me here.
Okay, alright, goodbye Uto.
Goodbye.
Wait, are you okay, Ditto?
I'm okay.
That one team there, but I think that's...
It's fine.
It's fine?
Is it actually fine?
Yep.
Okay.
I swear to God, if you're not fine, I swear to God.
Oh, liar!
I'm fine, I'm fine, I'm fine.
Are you sure?
You're in...
Okay.
One team here, no, I'm not fine.
Okay, okay.
Oh, okay.
All right, I don't I don't think I was fine
Every time I was not fine.
I was I was Yeah,
like I flexed you I'm playing Bangalore
Derek, I'm playing Bangalore
Okay Fuck's here Okay, I'm gonna pick on this Okay, nice,
nice, nice call, nice call Okay, this time this this time
this time we'll get champion right here I believe I believe
this time it'll be different there's no sound I turned on my
headphone but there's no sound behind me are you sure are
you sure did it up yes yes okay okay is your headphones on
correctly okay yeah wait did you turn apex sound on this is
why we need to play for 12 hours this is we always take two
hours for yeah yeah we need two hours to warm up okay let me
turn off my bpn i'm turning off my vpn this time
Let's go.
I'm not in the banner.
Alright, here we go.
Oh.
Why did it mute you guys?
When did it mute you guys?
Alright, where are we landing?
Uh, countdown?
No, here.
Come on.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can do it.
Look at us.
Oh, is this place?
Okay.
Don't worry.
We're prepped.
No, they land away.
They land away.
No, don't worry.
Don't worry.
One team, one team.
Yeah, one team is just one team.
We're so good.
I have a Mozambique.
I'm not good.
I'm not.
I have Mozambique, Mozambique.
Okay, okay.
You can do it.
You're prepped!
You're prepped too!
You're also prepped!
You can!
But Uto is poor!
Come here, come here!
Come here, pro, pro!
You need pro!
You say, you say!
Okay, okay.
Only one team.
All right.
One guy's there.
Okay.
I see him.
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
Alright, they can aim!
They can aim!
They're pro!
They're pro too!
I'm gonna kill myself!
I need a heal.
No sand!
No, he's streamer mode!
He is pro!
I'm gonna come to you.
No sand!
So at least we'll be together.
Wait, two teams?
Two teams!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Two teams.
Mommy?
Actually?
Oh my god, one here.
Wait.
What the fuck?
Wait!
What?
I thought it was so weird!
It's a new team.
New team.
Another new team!
Wait, they are bread!
I knew it!
I fucking knew it!
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
because we were look look that game we were trolling we were
trolling
look only prets can kill prets okay okay they're pred so
they killed us too if it was not pred players you know
they're higher pred ranked than us yes yeah okay okay and
they are poor because with all yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah they had they had two pros they had two pros we only
have one guys we only have one only have one pro it's not
fair they had two pros do you want to be a pro no I want to
have a life.
I want it.
Alright.
Condit can use Q like two times.
Oh, true, true.
True.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's pretty strong, I think.
We'll be so strong.
Yeah.
True.
We can't die.
Okay.
If we die, it's Uttar Fall.
Oh.
Oh my god.
They have a...
roller players they have two roller players it's over i
think i think everyone in this yeah it's over there why did
you get the silver we could have been in bronze no my game
crashed
don't drop yet no where's my no we we are learning we are
learning no don't worry i'm coming back Okay, okay.
I'm coming back.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Epic sender.
Don't worry.
I'm loading in.
It's okay.
You guys can't watch it.
I believe you.
Just don't land on another Pred.
Just don't.
Don't land on a pro team.
Yourself.
The pro team behind, um, near us, near us.
Wait, what?
I said don't.
It's...
I said don't land on the protein.
I don't know if they are poor.
Okay, okay, I'm here, I'm here.
I'm okay.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, I'm okay now.
Okay, where is team?
Where's enemy?
Um, climatizer.
Okay.
I think we can go kill them.
Yeah, we'll be fine, right?
I believe.
Okay, I'm heading over.
I have, I have loot.
I'll head over to Ditto.
Oh.
There's two.
Are they...
Is it one team or...
Only one team.
I have a 30-30.
I can poke.
Nice.
I'm looking.
Okay.
I'm charging my urge.
I don't see them.
Okay.
Is looted on the right side?
There's looted here too.
Don't see them.
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
Here.
Oh, Digi, I don't have...
Do we want to push?
Push.
Push?
Okay, okay.
Uta says push.
Oh, yeah, they're here.
They're here.
I see them.
They're on the right.
Okay, okay.
I mean, we can...
We didn't take this.
Yes, take a zip line.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You might hear it though.
Oh, I see, I see, see.
He's separated.
Okay, okay, okay.
His teammate, his teammate's up to the right.
Okay.
I'm going to Ditto.
I see one of them.
I don't know where it's- I know, inside, inside, inside.
One or two?
Inside.
Only one.
I'm here?
Where?
On me?
I hear him.
Up, up, up, up, up, up two.
Two?
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Three, three.
Three?
All three, okay.
RG, okay.
Then they'll know we're here.
Danos!
Wait.
Are they shooting you?
Are they shooting you at those?
Yeah, okay.
Oh, I don't know if we could get to them.
I don't know if we can climb up.
I don't know if that's smart.
I don't think- Yeah!
I'm gonna die!
Goodbye.
Oh
Okay, wait,
I got it.
I got it guys no I figured it out.
I should be playing mad maggie No, I know now.
Now we win.
What is Mad Maggie's kid?
I don't even know.
Now, this time, this time, this time.
This time.
We were just trying to find the best team comp.
You know?
We don't know what the best team comp is.
All right.
What is...
Okay.
The base team come.
Mad Maggie.
Really?
No, I don't know.
I don't know.
No.
Her aura is still good, I think.
I think her ball is really good, though.
Yeah.
This is it.
This time.
Okay, okay.
I believe.
Okay,
what is my thing?
Drill, gain an extra drill charge.
Ooh, big drill.
Holy shit.
That's insane.
We're just downloading right now.
Downloading meta.
Every game we play, we get better.
We're like AI.
Yeah, yes, yes, yes.
We're AI learning right now.
Chat GPT.
Every game we get stronger.
Is there a team here?
Nice.
Yeah, one team here.
With you.
Oh, shit!
Yeah!
Yeah, with me, with me, by the way.
Let me, okay.
Are you okay?
I'm okay, I'm okay.
He's like in here.
One team here.
Two?
Is this two teams?
Um, maybe there's already the same team.
They're the same team.
Okay, I'll back up.
Ben.
There's team and countdown too.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's the one in this building.
Do you want to push with me at all?
I can come over soon.
I have more than big.
You can play Yeah, you can play pro player can play with
Mozam Okay, okay, okay Go, come on Yeah, go!
Go, go!
Go, go go!
Oh, where are they?
Where?
Inside?
Yeah, yeah inside inside inside IB!
QB!
QB Okay, okay, okay.
I'm over?
Oh, crack!
One crack.
Hi- Hi ground?
Yeah, high ground.
Don't fall Ooh
Yeah, on me What the fuck?
I got beam so fast What the fuck It's okay, I beam them too
Yeah, that one What?
Holy shit That was so fast I forgot what it was like like to
have zero armor oh no they're resing okay whoever that guy
that killed me fuck that guy careful careful you guys can
like back up i feel like yeah yeah just res me over the the
fire side yeah that's just smart oh my god bro fuck that one
guy him and i died forgot
okay okay yeah and they're gonna come to us and we fight and
we win yeah yeah yeah yeah i have to get there careful oh no
she don't have to be careful she's poor oh yeah you're right
don't you don't have to be careful you'll be fine okay fuck
that okay oh
Okay, I'm coming over.
I need to... I'm gonna get high ground.
Because I'm scared now.
Are they?
You know?
Middle, middle, middle.
Oh, middle.
Oh my god.
Fuck that guy.
Okay, okay.
I don't have a long range.
Me too.
I will go get our army.
Yeah, it follows me.
I'm gonna go get the ditto.
I want to be together.
No, I'm after that guy.
I'm just scared now.
I don't have a backpack.
You still don't...
Wait, me too.
Me too.
I still don't have a backpack.
Wait, there's a blue armor here.
Not even a blue helmet.
I need a two.
There's no armor on the ground.
Where are they?
Are they still there?
I don't know.
I'm scared now.
No, I don't see one.
I don't see one.
yellow chain yeah that one guy gave me ptsd oh my god he
beam you yeah i i for that i can't give you too i lived for
one second i'll do this oh two better here oh nice nice nice
i think they they get they're inside the ring oh i mean
we're already in ring why do they need to go in ring when
we're already in ring oh you're right yeah like you're right
you're right it's got pizza
oh oh i still not i still not found a backpack i have zero
shield cells okay yeah oh nice
me oh i can't i can't find the score here badly wait they
scanned yo they're still there they're still there yep
revenge um okay all right you guys kill that one guy that
killed me and then uh and then i'll be fine
i need that i need that three oh where are they still um on
the building maybe hiding are they hiding dude fuck them
yeah careful you see i play there's a lot of team hind
really really cowards
cowards oh they went there they went down oh okay they're
fine that's fine but uh um um I need like...
We still don't have shield cells.
Do you need Valley?
No, I just need shield cells.
I only have two.
Okay, okay, I can't give you tea here.
I'm gonna check if there's any extra here.
Thank you.
It's okay.
I will take it.
Does anyone want 3x?
Crypto drone?
Oh, here, here, here, here, here.
Oh, shit.
Where are we?
I will go get here.
I will go to this building.
Over.
Where I'm looking at.
Jesus Christ.
He's crack.
Yeah, I have to heal.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, that is them.
They're GPK.
Wait, what?
Near me?
Near?
Yeah, near.
Okay, okay.
them near us.
Hey, hey, hey, hey!
Oh, backed up, backed up.
Two teams, two teams, two teams.
Two teams, two teams.
Uh, I'm gonna go to Ditto.
I wanna be here.
Okay.
Hey, that's my body.
Whoa!
Careful, Ditto.
Gets on the building!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go with, uh...
Be careful.
Be careful, look tall.
Yeah, go go high ground, go high ground.
Okay.
Uh, careful behind us.
Okay, um, I'm gonna go forward, Paul.
Hi, guys, Pandy.
Yeah, pretty scary.
Okay.
Let's see, team.
Scary.
Yeah, I might die.
I might do something stupid.
Finally, I get blue.
That's fine.
I-I-I want to fight the team behind us.
Oh, they're like all the way.
I think we should get a crack first.
Because they're...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This team is so annoying, though.
I'm burning one.
Yeah.
But you guys chill cells?
Um, I have tea.
Yeah, I need chill.
We're so poor.
Okay, I- Okay, I can't give you one.
That team is still white, white armor.
Leave us alone!
I'm gonna waste my heals.
Okay, I'll use my battery.
Oh, okay.
Oh my god.
Leave us alone!
Oh my god!
Bro, did you fuck this?
Fuck these... Oh my god!
Let us loot!
What a loot!
Fuck you!
Yeah, fuck you!
Let us loot!
Leave!
Oh my god, there's a crypt- Oh my god!
Okay, I'm batting.
It's fine.
Bro, fuck this crypto drone.
What the heck?
Why the show sucks?
Yeah!
Fuck you guys!
Yeah, that's fucking right.
Charge then um, another new team.
I sure there's so many new teams Is zone ending here I think
zone's ending here.
Why is there so many teams?
Yeah, there's one here, I
think Leave us alone leave Wait no wait fighting third party
third party we can third this oh shit.
Okay What is that?
There's a team.
We can third this if we want to.
Are we gonna go third?
Do we want to?
We can.
Hi, IGL.
We have no...
Third or no?
Wait, that's fourth party!
Fourth party coming!
Okay.
There's a lot of teams.
But we don't have...
We don't have anything.
We should...
We should.
We should go.
Get Luke.
Go to Luke.
We should.
We have, like, nothing.
Oh, fuck.
I fucked up.
Come,
come, come, come, come, come, come, come, come, come, come,
come, come, come.
Come, come, come, come, come, come, come, come, come, come,
I have, we got loot here.
We can loot this box for loot.
You can loot this box for loot.
What?
There's people here, there's people here, there's people
here It's a rear here Okay, there's a rev here Oh my god
Levo Yeah I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm Phoenix kidding, I'm
Phoenix kidding No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no Careful,
careful, I'm helping, I'm helping, I'm helping Careful,
careful Okay, use your shield I'm Oh, that's Okay, I have
to, I have to bat, I have to bat Nice one!
Nice one!
Anyway, see me!
Look, we had nothing!
We had nothing!
We were so poor!
Yeah, we're so poor!
What the fuck?
We couldn't lose!
Leave us alone!
They didn't let us loot!
Yeah, I had zero shields!
What do I do?
I just...
I just wanted...
I just wanted heals!
They were so poor.
It was so sad.
Oh my god.
No one...
No one wanted us to get anything that's so fucked up there
were three teams in sky hook and crypto there was five teams
there were more teams kept coming we couldn't go anywhere oh
my god that one building had like three teams that ran in
That was crazy Yeah, we are in the middle of Of the lane No,
no, of the team Yeah Like in the middle
Oh my god, that was like crazy Alright, I'm muted But I want
to say for those who are like Hide your map Alright, if you
Cannot fucking see If you need a map to know where I am
There's no way you can kill me Okay, I got...
You're not at skill level to kill me.
You need a map to know where I am.
It's not that good.
Yeah, okay, we're good.
Browna.
I have an alternator.
Okay, I have alternator massive.
Oh.
I have a rampage.
And a 3x.
Wait, do we have team here?
No, right?
No.
Oh, we're the countdown team.
We are the countdown team.
Yeah.
There's a lot of team in Skyhook.
Alright, let's do it.
We're the third partiers.
Okay.
We can do it.
Whoa!
Okay, that was a weird lag.
Okay.
Are you lagging?
No, I'm good.
I'm good.
I was lagging a little earlier.
All right, I'm good.
Let's go.
If you find hammerpoint, let me know.
Okay.
What are you using?
R.E.
Hemlock.
Okay.
I'll grab some of my ammo.
Yeah.
Nice.
All right, guys, ready?
I'm gonna grab some healers.
I'm ready.
Yeah, let's go.
Let's see.
Oh, they can't get fighting.
Let's go!
Hello!
Oh, I hear names.
They're fighting, they're fighting!
Go, go, go, go!
Yeah, you're here?
I think?
They're a lot closer.
Yeah, yeah.
No knocks?
Yeah, yeah, right in front of me.
Oh, another team shooting?
Here, here.
Three teams, three teams, three teams.
In this building?
Yeah.
Wait, someone near you, Uto?
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Uto, on Uto.
Come to me, come to me!
Come to me, come to me, I altered, I altered.
On you, on you!
Oh, we have to help Uto, help Uto.
I'm going.
I got one, I got one.
Oh my god, he's low!
So low, low, let it low!
Where, where, where?
Where, where?
Wait, wait, wait.
Above, above.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Oh, I'm dead.
Ah, fuck.
One guy here on the staff.
Two guys.
I know.
I can't.
I'm really low.
You can go back to countdown and carve us maybe.
Oh, yeah, maybe.
If they don't push me.
Kill me!
Yeah!
They might chase me, though, so...
Oh my god, that's R-star.
Yeah, you guys died so fast.
What the fuck happened?
Yeah.
Like, I got one creep.
I only have 9-9.
Yeah, I made a perfect aim with my 9-9, but I still lose.
Oh, because you're on R-9.
Yeah.
That's why you forgot.
useless i don't have i don't have another camera than r9 is
alternator better than r9 r e um alternator i mean i don't
know i just know oh i just know uh um r9 is so dog now yes
yes yes that's all i know all right chat okay apex players
in chat which one's better Or...
Alternator or...
I feel like Alternator gives more damage, I feel like.
Yeah, I feel like that.
Yeah.
Especially if you have...
Oh, they come, they come, they come, they come.
Oh, they're coming?
Where?
Ping, ping here.
Yeah.
I see them.
On the beach, on the beach too.
Uh, 80?
I'm trying to help you guys.
I'm covering.
Oh, come up, hello!
I see them there to my left.
I cracked the Watson.
The Watson's running here or left here.
But the Watson's here.
So it's one.
Watson is far from team, but careful of...
Okay, okay.
Careful.
I'm coming up.
Oh, let's crack, crack, crack, crack.
Okay.
I might run.
Use my knock.
Yeah, I'm gonna run.
I was like...
See you!
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
That's so fast!
Oh what the heck?
I mean...
My ear... I think my ear stayed.
What happened?
I didn't hear anything!
Dero, you can like sometimes...
You hear the... you hear like the smallest things or you
hear nothing
there are two two people on my left but i couldn't hear
anything when i realize it i think you're getting old to me
you're getting old no i was just 17.
you're no you're getting old okay okay it's it's time for me
to um okay it's time to open okay i will use my ear this
time you yes i forgot i i turned on my headphone but i
forgot oh yeah yeah yes guys this time this time this time
this time it will be different we we swear yeah
don't worry
Can't do it.
Can't do it is like can't do it.
How many excuses are we gonna have?
We're too heavy for Uto, Tero!
We got it.
What?
We're too heavy for her!
Yeah, we're too heavy!
We're too heavy!
Uto, we're too heavy!
Please boost us
Uto boost us
Uto I'll give you five dollars You pull more Okay six
dollars One membership I will give you one Dora one dollar
what the fuck did that was my house no this is mine what the
fuck this is why we're too heavy for her this is why we're
too heavy okay okay it got 199 again i got one get rid of
that all right maybe car would be better okay I can but I I
want um Polly Polly I found a lot of cars I haven't found a
single hammer point like where the fuck are the hammer
points?
And there's hammer points, but it's it's pretty um not not
not now, but I have ever seen hammer points.
Yeah hammer point is I haven't found one hammer point yet
Demo lock nice nice I'm gonna go Okay in this bin okay if if
i don't if i don't find power i will give you guys no oh i'm
gonna say i can find a pile or two there's pk here you know
our first game was our best game what happened to us
our first game we killed so many people what happened to us
yeah what happened to us
Maybe, maybe we have to Like, we have to...
Turn our hacks?
Don't worry, wall hacks on?
Wall hacks on?
Don't worry guys, this time.
Oh, I forgot to turn it on.
Now I remember.
Okay.
I have so many cell now.
I see there's people here.
Okay, use power.
Okay, I got power.
Nice.
Oh, there's people landed here.
Here.
Wait, there's two teams, two teams.
We can third party.
Okay, okay.
Are you going up?
I'm going to...
I'm gonna...
Yeah, they're fighting.
They're fighting.
over okay I see them are fighting okay I think they got
knocks they finish already no no no no no no no no no no no
no okay I'm so fast you're so fast yeah I'm so fast I'm
slowly
I'm going up Okay, I used my earth I'm going up Mommy Mommy
I locked myself It is your house Oh my god You owe me I know
you Guys They run away You run away Okay Yeah Last guy Last
guy That has to be last guy right there's one more there's
one more to you there's one more to you there's one okay
okay look I got confused I got confused accident yeah okay I
know this is why we keep losing I don't play What?
I don't know what you're talking about.
I am trying my best.
Okay, nice, oh, nice, oh, it's nice.
We won.
Did we not win?
Nice.
Okay.
We're gonna- We're hiding.
You got this!
Uto, go, go, go!
Nice!
See?
So easy.
Okay.
With the cube, I do it.
Nice.
Yeah.
What a game.
See, even if I ult you, we still win.
Okay.
So this team, we can bring.
Yeah, yeah.
It's all about...
I just need to ult you again, and then we win.
Oh, no.
Peace, no.
Anyone want battery?
Yeah, I'm good.
I have five.
Okay.
How about you, Todd?
Oh.
Badly.
Does anyone want these?
Okay, I have to give you two.
Purple stalking.
Oh, actually I'll take that.
Purple stalking, barrel stabilizer.
Does anyone want that?
Me.
Hey.
I'm gonna...
You want to scan again?
Can I scan?
Yeah, you want to...
You want to scan again?
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh yeah.
You can scan.
Yeah.
Scan here.
Oh!
No, nothing?
Nothing?
Take the most.
Okay.
What the, right here?
This one, this one, scan.
Right here.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Someone please give her GPS.
Yeah, yeah.
GPS.
Maybe that's why we're losing.
All right.
She okay.
I see she was gonna go dead Oh lava That was a lot I feel
like he's gonna be oh my god.
We saw she'll see there's no one near us.
Yeah, we're so there's no one near us There's a team here.
Where should we go?
I feel like Look at the lava Okay, lava Go through it.
Yeah, I'm as well I think I or we go here and then kill this
team Oh, you did say okay?
Yeah, because they have to come to us.
Oh, big drill.
All right.
We can do this.
If not champion, top three.
Top three.
I'm, I'm, this game, top three.
Come on.
You don't need, do you don't need champion?
This game, no, this game.
Look.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Just change your mind so fast.
Look, we were not lucky for her, okay?
We are not lucky.
Okay.
You see anybody?
I'm watching.
I'm looking.
I see no one.
I don't see anyone yet.
I don't see anybody.
Are they gonna come to us?
They should.
Wow, wow.
One enemy.
Far Let's see is there any scans here?
No, there isn't.
I mean we could they have to come here.
So Yeah, but I have no clue where are they?
They could they go here or here or tunnels Yeah, let's just
wait, but if if they if they went to landslide they will
they would meet another Yeah, it's quite That's true
We could...
Why?
Why am I the only one who...
Who have blue armor?
Because you don't shoot your gun?
No, I should.
I should.
Because you should have ulted at your teammates.
No, I know.
Because I got your urs.
I got urs.
Yeah.
Yeah, but I got purple though.
I ulted you and I got purple.
Oh!
Yeah, that's how it works.
Yeah, if you alt at me, you get purple.
I see.
Okay, I have to alt at you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Maybe I might get late army.
Oh, yeah, true.
Oh, yeah, if I frame me, frame me, frame me, frame me!
Almost kicked!
I didn't hit anything, by the way.
Purple armor.
Purple and late armor.
Yeah, purple and red.
Guys, I don't feel so good.
They're purple.
Wait, no, we have purple.
I'm gonna use single.
Oh, they're taking jump tower.
Why are we gonna do it?
Just shoot it.
They might walk up.
I think they'll walk up.
They did the jump pad.
The jump pad?
Okay.
Yeah, they just jump pad.
I don't see them.
Are they coming over?
Two over, one lane.
Yeah, they're coming down.
Behind the rock.
Behind the rock?
Okay.
One of my tanks.
The guy on Lifeline?
Whoa!
Okay.
Oh, me, oh me!
Almost cracked him?
Cracked him?
Regular crack, regular crack.
Last guy.
Help, uh, Hoto.
You have Q?
Yeah, Q?
Find it.
Here, here, here.
Nice.
Nice one!
Look, we did it!
Oh, we did it!
Top three, top three.
Okay.
No, okay.
No, no, top three.
Don't jinx it.
Okay, okay.
Don't chase it.
Top 3, top 3.
Top 3.
Oh shit, Eva 8.
I'm gonna grab the Eva 8.
I heard Eva 8 is so strong now.
Yeah, Eva 8 is so strong.
Last time I played Eva 8, I hit Nazi.
So I stop it.
Yo, that's not good.
okay oh maybe we can go from the right side yeah let's go oh
my god maybe top three someone's dying tough three top three
oh Eva You can pay it Yeah, Eva is- I have Eva already Get
the Eva, it's so strong How about two Eva?
Two evas?
Okay, you know what?
Two evas, let's go I'll do it Let's go I'm mad Maggie anyway
My inventory is Top 3, let's go!
Top 2, Top 2 Top 2 Top 2, Top 2, Top 2, Top 2 Top 2, Top 2
Wait, wait, wait, scan.
We can scan.
Oh, wait, no, we can't.
Never mind.
No scan, no scan, no scan.
That's not time.
No, no.
Dude, okay.
Okay, okay.
Are they fighting?
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Oh, my sky is so low!
Where, where, where, where?
Keep paying?
Over here.
I only have close range.
I have another one there.
I will take, I will go take.
Okay, I'm coming over.
Behind.
Behind behind behind behind here Under the pole Yeah yeah
the Second team is all over there I feel like Wait we're in
middle we're in middle We should go back We should go back
We're middle Yeah wait let's see Wait where is good There's
a team there isn't it?
Is there a team there?
Where can we go?
We're in the middle right now No we're in okay We can stay
here It's okay we can stay here Yeah we'll stay here We'll
stay here Yeah there's we're in between two teams teams yeah
another team there one team there and one team on the left
side guys i have eva 8 guys
what do i do we can we can do it and conduit okay okay okay
they have to make them push me it's like alarm okay i can't
die if i die they get two eva 8s They ended it.
That's too scary.
I don't want...
They have horizon!
They're over here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're coming?
What are they doing?
Stop!
We're gonna get third.
It's leave!
Leave!
What are you doing?
Oh, you're gonna die!
Someone make sure we don't get third.
Someone make sure we don't get third party.
I'm gonna make sure.
I'll look behind.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't want to get through, dude.
Where's the second team?
Yeah, my aim so good.
I see the second team over here.
Horizon, they trying to push us?
It's fine.
We have here.
No, it's fine.
They can't.
Yeah, they can't.
Behind the log.
Alright.
Team here and...
And then team here.
Purple.
We wait.
They push us.
How many people on the left side?
Um, I don't know.
I think there's two, maybe.
I'm lucky I'm I'm right.
Okay.
Okay, we wait until zone is small so I can...
So I can Eva 8.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, nice, nice.
I think they...
I feel like they're gonna push us.
It's okay.
This is alright.
team they push each other we're so we have zone we have zone
it's fine okay yeah we wait we wait we can be patient we
wait okay yeah we wait how horizon and bangalore we wait
it's fine behind the log here he ran up here i see him oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i saw you i saw it
i'm looking at my left right now right here okay are you
trying to you look you look right yeah Good left team.
Come on.
Get out of here.
I want him to fight.
Go get out of here.
Come here.
Get over.
Yeah.
It's so scary, isn't it?
My Eva A.
Yeah, make them fight each other.
My skin?
I think it's...
I don't know if that's one guy.
No, that's two.
It's two.
There's a guy right here.
Below me, below me, below me.
Okay.
They have horizon maybe.
They have my...
They're below me.
I need help.
Wait, wait, cover, cover.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Push, push.
No, no, no, no.
They're not pushing.
Oh, they might push.
They might push now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm backing up to you, Ditto.
To kick here.
Yeah, I'm coming from you.
Come to you.
Be careful.
behind the lock.
Okay.
Anyone have, um, energy?
No.
You have to,
uh, be careful.
I'm giving you each armor.
Yeah.
Yeah, two.
Yeah, yeah.
Get away from us!
Leave!
I'm backing up, I'm backing up.
Careful, Ditto, careful, careful, careful.
You're here, you're here.
Oh no.
Wait, behind us.
Oh shit, behind.
No, why did they fire us?
No, no, hide, hide, hide.
Oh god, no!
Okay, they're fighting each other.
Oh, wait, I'm safe, I'm safe.
I'm safe.
I'm trying to go down.
Yeah, it's just fine, just fine.
No, no, no, no, no come here, come on.
Come here.
Oh my gosh.
My gosh!
That's a lot!
Why are they all on us?
They don't fight each other.
My two Eva's!
I told you, top three.
You're right.
Oh, I'm so...
How are you?
They don't fight each other!
Why us?
We're such babies!
Okay, this time, this time.
This time?
See, I told you, top three!
Top three!
If we say champion, we might get champion.
Okay, okay, top two.
Oh my god, they were scared of my Eva 8 They were so scared
Oh my god No, you have two Eva 8 My Eva 8 Oh my god There
were no Eva I couldn't do anything Everyone was so far
Everyone was so far
but it's amazing if you um if you have another gun we might
um win that fight yeah if i had if i had another gun that's
not to leave but yeah yeah i i believed you're right if all
it is to eva it's my fault one son do you have l he was 16.
okay yeah it was it was stupid it was actually very stupid
so yeah i believe in us we're in silver we're in bronze we
don't lose anything if we die yeah oh i lost i lost you're
in silver silver doesn't matter
it's not that much yeah exactly it's not that much no one
returns okay nice I'm so I still have no hammer point where
the fuck is the hammer point I don't see any hammer point
yeah I haven't seen one either nice wait I would have won if
I had a third Eva 8 if I could if I was the what was his
name the old man with three Eva eights i would have won oh
yeah yeah if i was ballistic with three eva eights yeah
three eva eight ballistic oh my god all right all right all
right that's what i that's why i didn't win that fight okay
i want power and nemesis
Power, Nemesis.
I have Nemesis, uh, RE.
Ooh.
Okay, I'm gonna run 30-30.
Anyone want this?
Run!
Yeah, I do.
I'm coming over.
Okay.
I swear, I haven't seen a single hammer point.
It's been...
It's been like...
Like an hour and a half.
No hammer point.
I'm so sad.
Life is horrible.
Life is not fair.
And life is not fair.
Yeah.
I don't get it.
Where is my...
Where is my hammer point?
Hammer point.
I don't see one.
Let me see.
Hammerport Hammerport There's no hammerport There's a
prowler Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa Yeah, yeah, yeah Maybe it's
our comp We need to find The perfect comp Enemy!
We're coming, we're coming I'm coming Where?
Where?
Here?
Here, here, here.
High ground one.
Okay.
Yeah, on the high ground.
Revenant and Bloodhound.
Okay.
I see him.
Track.
Nice.
I'm going, I'm going.
Careful?
Oh.
I'm looking.
Okay.
I'm out.
I'll come over to you High ground.
Oh fuck that might be oh, I'm good.
I'm good.
I'm okay.
I'm okay Nice, I knock one on me.
Oh my god.
He fucking ran at me careful careful
I'm helping On you on you on you too Hey last last guy last
guy Oh I'm
baiting He's so much better!
Yeah, fuck you!
Go back to Sylvie with us!
Because we're friends!
Nice!
Let me just go.
Let's go, let's go guys.
Okay, I have to heal for us.
Hammer point?
No hammer point.
The hammer point.
I'm gonna slow heal.
I don't want to waste my med kit.
Okay.
They don't have much.
Yeah, they did.
Oh, that Rev.
Oh, that was so scary.
Nice.
Oh, yeah, that Rev always...
You know what?
Nah, I know.
I need to play Rev.
If I play Rev.
Yeah, I have to...
If I play Rev champion.
It's because I wasn't on Rev.
Hello.
Do we have any beacons?
What did they buy from the other one?
Nothing.
I don't know.
But Rev seems strong.
Yeah.
Where do we go?
What the?
Okay.
Every center?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we have scanner too.
Oh, we can't see a scan here first.
Oh, yeah.
I'll scan first.
Oh, my God.
We forgot.
Oh, yeah.
Sorry, our monitors are turned off again.
Let me shake.
Where are people?
Nobody.
Oh, here.
Wait.
Here, one team.
Near us.
No, they know, they know us.
No.
That's what...
Has finder.
Has finder and what was that?
Lace.
Okay, I'm heading over.
Okay.
That's the Luridine.
Okay, I'll walk over.
They know us.
Okay.
If I die, I might die.
If you die, I...
You clutch.
I run.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, you clutch.
Oh, okay.
You clutch, remember.
If I die, it will crash.
Yeah, yeah.
So...
It's going inside?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Two.
Octane almost kicked through army.
Yeah, there's one guy below us.
Over there?
Yeah.
Careful of under.
Oh.
Whoa!
Okay, I'm backing out a little.
I'm backing out.
Careful, they might grapple.
They might zip.
Careful.
Okay.
I'm healing?
I'm gonna do this so they don't come up.
Oh wait, sorry, I missed.
Oh, careful.
Scan.
Nice scan.
Maybe one guy might be so close to us.
Be careful, be careful.
I need a shield cell.
Oh, I hear them beside me?
They might... Oh, here!
Follow me.
Right here.
Oh!
Okay.
Careful, careful.
Luto, heal, heal.
Scan, scan.
Heal, heal, Luto.
Under, under, under.
I knock one, I knock one, I knock one.
Okay, I'm coming over.
Okay, okay, okay.
Reshing?
Reshing.
I need help though.
I'm bad, I'm stealing.
Oh, no.
Oh, so low, so low.
I can't, I can't.
Oh, another team, another team.
Another team?
Okay, I'm backing him back.
Yeah.
Careful here.
Behind, um, in front of you.
Yeah, this is bad.
Yeah.
Can't be out of here.
Okay, here.
Be nice.
Oh, I'm gonna start off, you guys.
Yeah.
There's no point in fighting this.
Oh, someone kill me!
Someone kill her!
Please!
There's no one!
Crawl to them!
Why?
Please!
Keep ignoring me!
Crawl to them!
I can't craft you if you're still alive!
There are!
Die!
Oh my god!
Okay, I will go to you.
Crawling them!
I will go to you.
I can't craft because you're still alive!
Oh!
Dino, crawl to them!
Make them kill you!
You have...
Have a different...
I almost...
I almost die.
Wait, wait.
Wait for this time.
What are...
I'm gonna craft right now.
Dino, crawl to them right now.
Okay.
Wait, wait.
I'm gonna die soon.
Okay, I'm dying.
I'm dying.
Are you dead?
Okay.
Dino, why did you die faster?
Oh, sorry.
Okay, I'm resting here.
We're late here and we go, um, if I say this, okay.
Why did no one kill you?
They don't kill me.
No one wanted to kill you.
You were alive.
You were alive for too long.
Oh my god.
Maybe I'm too useless.
There's no one gonna kill me.
They feel so sorry for you.
They didn't want to kill you.
They're like, no, this- it's too sad.
Yeah.
Okay.
Wow.
Oh my god, there's actual- I'm so fast.
Alright, let's go check epicenter then.
We're still fighting.
You wanna look at it?
Or no?
Um, do you want it?
at it we don't have to fight it's over oh yeah it's over
yeah i want to take high ground though just in case okay can
you still wait here yeah you guys can live here i'm just
making sure our high our high ground safe it's loaded but
okay yeah see if there's extra loot well you can did you
scan do we scan ep yet no right no yeah we took his scan epi
epi okay okay okay and ab i have some valley here
i like new crafting it's so so fast yeah but you can only
craft once yeah you're fighting on the high ground here okay
i'm trying to make sure our high ground's safe though oh i
see people here okay Oh, I'll get a zone soon.
Okay, I'm gonna hide down.
Red armor?
I want to make sure they don't come to us, these guys.
Oh, they're one team there.
Oh no, one team, one guy, one guy, guys!
One guy, one guy!
Team right here where I'm looking at?
Okay.
Q!
Q, this guy!
This team is coming to us!
Yeah, there's a team coming to us here.
I'm coming to you guys.
I can't give you...
Wait, oh wait, fuck!
Oh shit, okay.
There's team here.
There's a team here.
I'm dead, I'm dead.
Oh, the team came to me.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's fine.
Leave me, leave me, leave me.
You guys can craft me.
Wait, I'll die the zone.
I'll die the zone.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm dying the zone and you can craft me.
you in here yeah i didn't realize how fast they were to me i
heard they were that close it's there i see that's how you
die ditto that's why that's how you die
wait where's this okay where's the lace where's the rest
yeah Okay.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
What?
Oh, shit!
Oh, he's trying to try and get...
Okay, okay, it's fine.
Just rest.
Yeah, we still can cover.
Okay, okay.
Come on, come on.
Come on.
Maybe he's...
I think he was trying to rest.
I think he wanted to rest.
That's really it.
Alright, nice.
I have zero touch.
We gotta go zone.
Let's go.
We're so poor.
No ammo.
Heavy.
A little bit.
Oh, no.
I don't have it.
Oh, below us, below us, right here.
Is this a team that killed me?
I think this is a team that killed me.
Yeah, there's one team.
Wait, nice.
Oh, very little, very little.
I need a healer.
No, no, no, no, no team, no team.
Come to me, Uto.
Come to me, come to me, come to me, come to me.
Back up, back up, back up.
I think we need to go a different way.
We might have to go drop down.
Yep.
Whoa, whoa, be careful.
Might have to arm start?
Yeah.
Oh, I stuck him.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
I stuck, I stuck, it stuck.
We can be right below them.
Yeah, we can't get below them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hey, they can't do anything.
Yep.
Here.
Oh, look over there.
They can't do anything about us here.
And they'll say drop down.
I don't think they'll drop down.
They're not.
Yeah, they don't want to.
Okay, they miss.
Do you have shields or no?
Whoa.
I'm safe here.
I'm safe.
Don't worry.
We're safe.
We're so safe.
We're so healthy.
Okay, we're fine.
Okay.
We're so healthy.
Do you have a shield cell, Suto?
I have a shield cell.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I will give you guy Q.
Okay.
Oh my god, no, no, we can't, we can't.
We can't, we can't.
This team is gonna drop down on us.
Unless...
okay oh my god leave us alone
we're so poor okay wait do you think we can run okay who oh
my god we can't be um um okay okay three three two one go we
run oh okay okay okay okay okay okay Okay.
Okay.
Careful, be careful here.
In front of me.
It's fine.
Let's go, guys.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Don't look back.
We're okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
We're safe.
We have to close the door on us.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Yeah, come here!
Come here, come here!
One, only one!
One, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, it's me.
Stop, kill solo.
Q solo.
No, okay, okay, okay, other team, other team to my right.
Wait on side.
Keep it on side.
I got him, I got him.
Nice one, nice one.
Last team over here.
Here, here, here, here, here.
You're out.
Shut your out.
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna try and charge my all.
Oh, shit!
Okay, okay, I'm trying to get my all.
I'm burning one.
He's on...
It's a rev!
Careful, Zeno!
Oh no.
I'm coming over.
Oh no!
No!
Top two!
We did it!
Next game!
Next game champion.
Nice, nice.
We did our race.
We were so poor, but we did it.
Why are we always so poor?
We're always so poor.
Okay, now...
Now, champion, I'm reven- No, champion.
I'm playing- Two and one.
I'm playing mystery heroes right now.
Okay, two and one.
Now champion.
This is it.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice.
Oh my gosh.
There's no way.
We can't.
We can't fuck up.
We got top three.
We got top two.
Now it's champion.
Champion.
Go.
All right.
Let me see.
Shadow, Palance, Cool Down, Reset.
Reduce, Tactical, Cool Down.
Which one's good?
We were so poor, but we'll still get second.
We were so poor.
I don't know how we did that.
I don't know how we were able to.
We did not like twice.
Attack for more.
total shallow pounds charge time cool down reset on knock um
two teams okay i don't know i should get agile assassin or
grim leaper grim leaper yeah only one all right we got this
um i wait i land here i'm landing here oh no two teams two
teams two teams two teams oh no three teams what the heck
three teams that's not good Wait, did I just hear someone
near me?
Yeah, someone's near me.
I have like this.
Be careful, Doki.
Yeah.
I'm coming over, please don't get shot, please don't get
shot.
I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay.
Two, two, two, two.
Are we gonna fight them?
No?
Do it, let's just go.
We're in silver.
Go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're in silver.
Okay, okay, okay.
I don't know where they are though.
Inside this one?
I think.
Careful to know you're by yourself.
Woohoo!
Nice.
I got to heal myself.
Oh, very low!
Revenant very low.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I want to know where...
Where, where, Revenant?
Nice.
Nice one!
Maybe that's rare?
Nice!
Oh, you paid rare!
Yeah, see?
We just need Rev.
Rev champion.
Okay, I need, um...
Silent.
I need like 150 for...
Wait, is there more?
Oh!
Oh, he got all of this.
Oh, I should have...
use my med kit.
I didn't want waste.
Double charger.
Up, up, up.
Do you have more syringes or no?
In a station?
Do you have syringes or no?
Um, I have two.
Okay, I have late.
It's fine.
I... I have zero.
I didn't... I thought I had more.
Oh, I have all!
Nice.
Okay.
Where are they in chain?
I can't... I can't get one.
Okay.
Uh, no, it's fine.
It's fine.
Oh yeah, here.
I have ult.
Nice, okay.
They're all high ground though.
The guy right here.
I can upgrade my push.
It's mine!
Whoa, so careful, careful.
Be careful, be careful.
Can you cue her?
Are they pushing or no?
No, no, no, they're not.
They're not.
They're not pushing.
I feel like we can chill.
Do we have enough meds?
I don't have main.
I don't know if we should fight this.
We don't have a lot of meds.
We get back up.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's just back up.
Yeah.
And loot more.
I don't think we have enough healers for this.
Wait, wait, wait.
Another team here.
Another team.
We have to go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Another team all night.
I know that's why I won't go here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's a wingman.
Oh my god, that's a wingman.
No, we don't have the heels for this We're too poor not
looted Not looted wait.
No looted looted.
Oh, he's looted.
Yeah, maybe there's scraps.
Maybe there's a team There's stuff here Oh here enemy enemy
enemy enemy enemy enemy Okay, okay Um, I should go We could
go Back I don't have a lot of heels i don't meet you let's
go let's go yeah i don't want to fight okay okay my heels
are so bad me too i have zero syringes i'm just a little
baby i'm just a little baby hello i crowded oh my god the
way it comes
I'm just up What the fuck Where is the syringes?
I can't keep you on here I can't wipe on you No, I'm too
lazy I already jumped I jumped already What the fuck are the
syringes?
This is looted This is looted Okay Okay Wait there's Oh no
it's half looted nice where they got there's people fighting
above me like here oh no oh yeah yeah one team above you
careful careful okay wait wait wait maybe we can we can yeah
yeah um yeah shoot shoot the back that's what i'm doing oh
let's go let's go let's go i'm coming i'm coming
I think they know, they know.
Oh, they...
Yeah, they do.
They do.
They knew, they knew.
I can't go on.
Nice, nice, I'm going back up.
Let's just kill me kill me.
Back back back back back.
Oh, back back.
Okay, okay, okay.
We don't have we don't have no Come on back I need 13 more
Oh my god be so poor again.
Why are we hoping?
No money Where's our money?
Please donate to us a lot of sign issue but can you guys
pick that up for me I'm too lazy okay okay and someone
donate us some some money to so we cannot be poor yeah it's
a sign just oh nice donate your donate your materials to us
okay I will go grab um the evil over there oh yeah maybe we
can go Sophie camp how about Sophie camp yeah let's go there
Where the fuck is?
Yeah, I'm like 13 from...
14.
I want to call up 2.
Or team poverty.
We're so poor.
I'll grab the...
the evo harvester.
Okay.
Oh no, there's one team here.
Alright, there's a team here!
Yeah, they just take the save.
Leave!
We want to loot!
Hey!
15?
I have like short range.
Oh, I fucked it that up.
Okay.
My god.
There's loot!
That's not alert.
Wait, where did he go?
Let me?
Yeah.
Oh, he went all the way there.
Oh, is he resing?
I think he's resing.
Oh, you okay?
Yeah, yeah, he's resing.
We threat this.
They have loot!
Okay, go, go, go!
Go, go, go, go!
Go, go, go!
Okay, okay, okay!
We're gonna be less poor here!
I'm going on the back, I'm going on the back.
I'm flanking, I'm flanking.
Where are they?
Careful, careful.
I'm here here.
Inside the tunnel.
Any help?
One tunnel?
Crypto?
Oh, don't go help.
What on Mickey?
Crypto cracked.
Kek, two Firebase.
Careful, careful, careful, careful.
Don't, no, no, no, no.
Careful, careful.
Like, that's just thirst.
Wait, I'm feeling, I'm feeling.
Wait, what the fuck?
Why is this so long?
Rob him!
Take his money!
Only two, only two, only two.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We thirsted one, we thirsted one.
Wait, wait, team behind, team behind.
Okay, okay, okay.
Team behind, team behind, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, oh my God, I have nothing.
We still have nothing.
We couldn't rob the guy.
I'm going to rob this guy.
Okay.
Leave us alone, please!
We just watched the live!
They're push, they're gonna push.
The team?
Yeah, okay.
I'm looking I'm looking behind I'm looking right I'm looking
right I'm looking right Yeah, I'm looking left.
I'm gonna I'm covering left right now
Please are they gonna push us?
No, they're not they're not they're not they're not they're
not they're not Wait, I think so one's one's close one's
close one close.
One close.
Okay.
Yeah I hear him Okay, if they push I would I would He's
super close.
He's super close.
Do you have Q?
With the Q Q Q Thank you.
I kicked one.
I got it.
No, no, no.
Push, push, push, push.
Last one, last one, last one.
Last one, last one.
Flash, flash, flash.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Thanks for the line.
Oh my god.
Yum, yum, yum.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Oh my god.
Finally.
Finally we have the loot.
That was so sad.
That was like the saddest game.
Okay.
I heard people in...
Oh wait, nice.
More loot here.
I can't upgrade my perk.
What is this?
I want to check if there's people here.
I think they do...
Yeah, we can go- we can stay- stay here.
We just stay here.
I don't want to go inside.
Oh, me too.
Yeah, inside is.
Yeah, me too.
Let- let's- let's look for people.
Okay, I'm gonna craft a bat.
Anyone need that?
No, I don't think so.
It's in this box.
Kraber!
Who wants the Kraber?
Ooh!
Oh, that's- it's- that's pretty far.
like right next to us actually yeah never mind it is never
mind it's like right here okay but i don't know it might be
too dangerous because it's in the middle okay i mean i can
try and get it i'll try and get it oh i'll drop my i'll drop
my parlor for it okay i will look a lot if there's any sure
i don't die yeah okay who wants the craber um i don't i
don't use craber or no?
No.
No, no, no.
No, no.
No, why?
Why does he...
I love my nemesis.
Over here?
It's fine.
They're farther, farther, farther, farther.
I'm fine.
I was...
It flies.
I'm covering you.
Yeah, it's fine.
I cracked him.
There's a bow check right here.
I'm good, I'm good.
Two blue, two blue there.
I'm okay.
I will keep these players.
This place is pretty good.
Okay.
I will make sure if there's no one come from our right side?
Yeah.
They're here.
No one, no one, no one.
Our right side, no one.
Yeah.
There's people fighting itself too.
This is fighting.
Oh, I'm looking.
100 and 6.
Maybe I can crawl.
Yeah, I think so too.
There's a team right here.
Oh, there's a guy right here in front of me.
Okay.
Okay, I want to.
He's right here.
Okay.
Oh, I missed.
roll down.
Come on.
He's like sliding.
Oh my god, there's someone come.
Someone come here.
Help me.
Oh my god.
There is some...
I'm gonna get back.
I'm gonna go back.
I'm going.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Oh, there's... Okay.
I don't think...
Guys, I should not have Craver.
I shouldn't have Craver.
Guys.
One guy.
Someone take this Kramer off me.
One guy, one guy.
There's a guy here.
Take it, you use this.
Don't, don't, don't crave for for me.
Wait, where's the Pathfinder?
Oh.
Yeah, they were dead.
Oh shit, look at that collab.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
this this huh oh nice where the fuck is that pathfinder
though inside one knock one knock one knock okay okay i
don't know we should finish them yeah nice one team there
i'm so scared of the pathfinder behind me okay nice uh let's
see i have five bullets left um i hit like three of those
bullets So...
See, you see a Pathfinder behind me?
I see your Pathfinder behind me?
Oh, careful.
Oh, Pathfinder here?
Oh, wait, he's on me!
Yeah, behind the one.
She's dead.
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice.
Only two, only two teams left.
One team duo and full party.
Two team there?
Yeah.
The sliding, the sliding, the sliding.
Oh, very, very, yeah, yeah.
Am I right?
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna come to you, guys.
Oh!
Sit down.
Whoa.
Oh my god, it's not editing, though.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna heal.
Let me just...
I couldn't swap my guns.
Where are they again?
Uh, up top.
High ground?
High ground.
When's high ground?
I got okay
Okay, okay 140 He's not gonna peek now No, my door Maybe we
can play Here I just don't want to be in the middle Okay,
okay As long as we're not in the middle, we're fine We can
go later, we can go later Yeah, yeah Is that one rat?
Is that a rat?
No It's full team, full team.
Oh, okay, okay.
Full team and one team duo.
Okay.
Oh, they knocked that one, knock one.
Okay, okay.
One to twelve?
Oh, nice one!
Nice one!
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
I want, I can't.
I thirst, thirst, thirst, thirst.
I'm healing.
Only two.
Careful, careful, inside.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
On me?
Give me a kill.
Burning one?
I
don't think we should...
I don't think we should fight this now.
We should wait.
No, no, only... There are two team.
There are two two team.
Yeah, but...
They're resing.
Oh, they're resing too.
They res, they res, they res.
You can lest me here, you can lest me here.
Okay.
I'm trying to cover.
I'm covering, I'm covering, I'm covering.
He's looking at me?
Oh no.
Keep crawling, keep crawling, keep crawling to me.
Keep crawling.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
They're fighting, they're fighting.
That's why I'm chilling.
Just crawl, just crawl, just crawl.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm resing, I'm resing.
You heal, you'll heal, I res.
Do you have Q?
Oh, you use Q.
No, no.
Nice, nice.
Batting, I'm batting.
I'm batting here.
Careful with the Q.
Udo, drop, drop, drop.
Oh, oh.
Reviving.
Flash, flash, flash, flash.
Oh, fuck.
Give you Q.
Q, Q, Q, Q, Q.
Oh no, I don't have Q.
I don't have Q.
I'm batting.
I'm healing.
Full heal.
I can't arrive.
Just rest.
You rest, you rest, you rest.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Give me Q.
Give me no.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Where are they?
Above, above, above.
Above.
I'm fine, I'm fine.
I'm batting.
But can't pull heal, pull heal.
It's 2, 2, 2, 2, 2, 3, 2, 2, 2, 3.
Okay, 2, 2, 2, 3.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, careful.
I have one Kraber shot.
Oh my god.
It's...
I have the bat.
I have no bat.
Oh, of course.
Can I scan again?
Okay, it's 3-3-2.
3-3-2.
I'm waiting.
Just wait, just wait, just wait.
Chill.
Okay, okay.
I hope I got that, I got that cell.
Scan?
When do you have Q?
Me!
Yeah, now, now, No.
Okay.
Give me?
Give me Q.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I give you, I give you.
Flash, flash, flash!
Okay, only one G.
Armor swap, you have to.
Can't can't you?
Oh, no.
I'm dead here.
Oh, I couldn't.
I had only one gun left.
We're so close!
I only had one gun!
Oh my god There was like three times Yeah That's you Oh my
god I have I had another gun If I had another gun It was so
close We almost got champion Oh my god I should help I
should help finish them No They had hammer point We were so
close!
Where is he finding Hammerpoint?
Okay, I'm going to be right back in his bathroom.
Okay, okay.
I'm back.
we can same team same team okay i bet you we can get
champion if i find hammerpoint okay okay i just i just need
hammerpoint we were so close only only hammerpoint yeah
okay I was so close It sucks my hammer point I can't believe
I can't believe they Resed three times They didn't push them
We didn't have DG either too Do you have a team?
Yeah, they're a team team One team one party one party In
front of me Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh It's my thing Oh
Oh my god.
Okay, you got...
That's me so...
We're so lucky.
Okay.
I got car and...
Spitfire.
Oh, I got left side.
All right.
I'll go.
I'll look at my side just to be sure.
Oh.
Oh, they're coming nowhere.
They're coming over.
You're not there.
Okay.
Oh, zero.
Two, two, two of them.
Okay, I'm heading over.
So close, so close.
Yeah, all three.
I'm coming over and coming over.
They're all three on you.
One clock.
I'm coming over.
Oh no!
So close, so close.
Careful, so close.
Careful.
Careful, careful, careful.
I'm trying to help you.
Flash?
One down.
Nice one down.
They're pushing, they're pushing, they're pushing.
It's like, oh no.
Oh, no.
They're low, okay.
Okay, low, okay, low, two low, two low, two low.
Okay, okay.
Where?
No armor, no armor.
Okay, where did he go?
That was bad for me.
Oh, he had the cue.
Oh, and oh, they push you guys so fast.
Yeah, they push.
That's so unlucky.
Oh, if I push...
I didn't think they would push so fast.
I was too slow behind.
I was still running.
Nice try.
Okay, okay.
That doesn't count.
That game doesn't count.
We don't have hammer point.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
because no hammer point every time we lose no hammer point
okay okay yeah that's the only reason why we lose
yeah fine hammer point win yeah fine hammer point equals win
exactly okay okay
we can do it I believe in us yeah look everyone in gold
right now they're like master players Master's plus, okay?
No, but we are paid.
We are paid.
We're paid.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
But, but, but, like, you know, we're, our ping is like 500
ping, remember?
Oh, oh, yeah, I forgot.
I forgot.
And they're fighting hammer points.
How?
Okay.
What the fuck?
They're all gold.
It's...
All right.
You know what?
Here we go.
We go here.
Okay.
Hot drop.
I believe in us.
Wow.
Two.
Two teams.
What the fuck is wrong with them?
Maybe they like us.
Oh, two.
They, the Lance Gator.
Why is that?
Is that the Mirage?
Is it?
No, no, no.
If it's not, it's third party.
Oh, okay.
Good, good, good for us.
Good for us.
Got a gun.
I got a gun.
All right.
Are we gonna go?
One, one, one, one, one, one, one, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm going over here.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
It's okay, you're strong.
Go!
I believe, I believe.
Come here.
Oh wait, no wait.
Okay.
Scan, how she?
Yeah, scan.
They're rising?
I think they res, they res, I think, wait, wait, just wait.
Oh, nice.
Okay, I know one.
Only four.
Oh, wait, where are they?
Two, two here.
Two here.
Oh, come here.
Get a photo.
Two here.
Oh, no.
I'm coming here.
No!
Two.
Crack.
No.
Wait, where's the other team?
I mean, they run away They run away, really?
Why?
I thought, where's the other team?
Yeah, a little team The other team go What?
How dare they?
I won't report them.
I can't believe it.
What's the point of third party if we can't third party what
they they worried that but okay they I bet they were I bet
they were walling I bet they knew I bet they were walling uh
aligned to paper okay oh anyway the only reason why we die
is because we don't have hammer point oh yes yeah turn turn
turn turn Yeah.
I can't believe it.
It's so mean.
They're so mean.
They won't let us third party.
So mean.
I know.
You're so mean.
Yeah.
I'm gonna report them.
Whoever they are.
Can't believe it.
Those fucks.
Okay.
This time I will be more careful.
I believe in us.
Yeah, I believe in us.
Oh.
Countdown?
Alright, yeah.
I went the wrong way.
Oh, that's...
No one countdown, I think.
I heard you say countdown, and I was like, okay, straight
down.
No.
I didn't count down.
I just hear down is there anyone here on us we go down yeah
oh one team one team oh no no no no oh a liar no I saw
someone above us whoa the server is yeah a car
sad.
The R9 is so garbage.
R9 is so bad now.
It's so sad.
Why is the R9 so bad?
I want them to buff R9 back.
Me too.
I feel so fucking weak.
It's so weak.
Yeah.
I'm not gonna carve.
I will keep it.
Oh no, I forgot to.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, I got a, I got key.
Let me know you guys find a backpack.
I have no backpacks.
Backpacks?
You want a prowler?
Two, two, two.
Okay.
Two backpack there.
Yeah, I'm getting it.
Oh, okay, power.
I got a 30-30 and a...
What do I have?
I have...
Oh.
Attack.
What is it so hard to find?
Have you guys ever seen one?
Yeah.
Have you ever seen one at all?
Two times.
Two times?
Yeah, two times.
In your life?
Yeah, yeah, in my life.
What the fuck?
What is the spawn rate of that stupid attachment?
Maybe you have to go to the...
I thought...
Huston?
If you go to Huston, that might be...
Oh, maybe.
I have a key.
Wait, wait, no.
Maybe in the vault.
I have a vault key.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
In your whole life.
I mean, in your season, in your season, I only see two
times.
Yeah, I saw it like one time in the new season.
Alright, come on.
Hammerpoint, just a gold bag.
Same as Turbo Shine.
Come on, Hammerpoint.
Disrupting.
Hammerpoint, Hammerpoint, Hammerpoint.
I took everything.
Wait, does anyone want this?
everything who wants to take that who's resing you need do
you need this uh okay i i will okay i think you should have
it i think conduit should have it okay okay the queue is
better okay okay no no uh ditto ditto ditto yeah reach one
you can have yeah nice okay okay okay there's people
fighting in fragment
In fragment, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, it got all gold.
All gold.
Go, go.
Alright, I don't know where they...
Okay, let's see first.
Yeah, they were here.
There's a...
Oh, I see them.
Wait.
We're here?
Oh, we're there, we're there.
Are you fighting, no?
No, they- I think they finished.
Yeah.
And the meter?
Do we want to fight or no?
Can we fight or no?
Yes, fight or no fight.
Fight, fight!
Okay.
Okay, let's fight.
All right, let's go!
Go!
I don't know where they are.
Me too.
I lost them.
Oh, to your right, right, enemy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Are you taking...
Hi, girl.
Blue?
Two blue.
Here, here, here, here, here.
Crammed?
Here?
In front of me?
Here.
This corner, this corner, this corner.
Okay, okay, okay.
Horizon 2, Horizon 2.
thing.
I'm going over.
Whoa!
Hit.
Cracked him.
Cue me.
Can you cue me?
Nice.
Yes, no, no, no, no.
Okay, nice.
I got one.
Got one.
Hold on.
Go down, go down.
Almost came out over there.
Yeah.
Almost came on my team.
Oh, I'm packing up.
They're little...
Okay.
His teammates here.
Can you...
I'm gonna go.
Beaks thirst him or no?
Yeah, they're running.
They're running.
They're gonna run.
Oh, wait over there.
Almost K!
Line.
They're so annoying.
I'm batting?
Okay, I'm going- I'm- I'm pushing and pushing.
Okay.
Do you have scan?
Scan.
They're like super split.
Yeah, I'm pushing up.
I'm pushing up.
They scan me.
I'm going up.
Okay.
I'm going up too.
On me?
Wait, behind me?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
I'm a bat real fast.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, they're super split.
Push this guy, push this guy.
He's split.
That's Rave!
They're so cute.
You have cute?
Let's go.
Yep, yep.
No, I don't have cute.
Oh, okay.
You don't have cute.
I'm pushing back me out then.
Wait, I'm getting shot from two angles.
teams two teams two teams two teams okay are you down are
you going down yeah yeah yeah back out back out back out
back out two teams two teams i'm gonna back out i'm backing
up i'm i'm i'm back i'm going back i'm going back make
her we need to construct her again okay okay okay we can
remake her just run now now i like two teams yeah yeah one
has a wingman and i don't fuck with that okay okay all right
man is scary we can make we can we can craft it here okay
i'm gonna shin my gun i'll craft her okay oh shit okay it's
fine good all right you can raise her here yeah i got it i'm
gonna start here thank you oh i feel like we can build her
stronger
all right we're fine see nothing to worry about yeah like
she never died thank you thank you thank you we're so far
from zone i don't have heels i want to i'm gonna go zone i'm
going here okay wait there's people here there's people here
okay you good no i'm pretty far from you yeah i'm just
trying to see if i can okay i'm doing cheer okay oh nice
nice nice aim no no it was not okay it was very bad i was
trying to finish them yeah finish this guy there's another
it was it was very sad i know i can't i can't finish them
it's okay we need to go zone we need to go zone i don't want
to yeah because you they're going to revive that guy okay
well it's two people it's two no no wait wait they're
fighting they're fighting okay Yeah, yeah, yeah, we can...
We're third.
Do you want to go third?
Yeah.
You might have heals.
Okay, I will...
I will use my oot.
I got what?
Nice.
Um...
Is it okay?
Have his shield.
Give me one.
Uh...
Die, die, one die, one die, one die, one die.
That's what I said?
Okay, there's still another.
No more?
Are they all dead?
Oh, they all dead to my oot!
Nice.
Here, here.
Whoa!
Oh my god!
We did it!
Holy shit!
Wait!
Holy fuck.
Wait, can I get rid?
No, I can't.
Oh my god.
Wait, where's the hammer portal?
Who has it?
Where?
I have my point!
Okay.
Nice, nice, huh?
Okay, I'm gonna medic it.
Oh my god, so, so, so...
Oh, wait, do I get this off?
Do I get this off?
So... Yes.
Okay, I'm okay.
Yeah, this don't hurt, it's like hell.
Yeah, so hurt.
Oh my god.
it.
This is it.
I forgot to grab Digi, but this is it.
I'm just missing Digi.
Let's go, only one.
One minute.
One minute left.
Okay, it's fine.
We can go from here.
I have three med kids.
Okay, okay.
I have one but yeah, I'm fine.
I can give you oh, yeah, I can give you one later.
No.
No mediki.
No more?
Okay, I can give you, though.
Thank you.
One team, one team they are fighting.
Oh my god!
I'm gonna die.
Wait, what?
I forgot.
Did you forget to heal?
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I forgot to heal because I was yelling at your name.
One team.
Okay, okay, I have to heal.
I have to heal too.
I have to go zone.
Okay, I'm good.
Oh my god, the first time I've ever seen a hammer point.
Nice.
The second time.
You got hammer point.
I finally did it, everybody.
We don't have much time.
We have to go.
Maybe we can go from the left side.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can go.
Okay.
I give you syringes.
Do you have syringes for her or no?
Ah, yeah, yeah.
I can give her one.
I'll give her one.
Okay.
I only have two.
I will give her one here.
Thank you.
one then okay there's someone with a craber i have i have
nine battery but i have only one silence someone has a
craber careful my right side here here here wait what
nice i don't know where his teammate is though oh the craber
craber careful careful careful Careful.
I want...
I want to thirst this guy.
The time to race.
Scan, scan, scan.
Scan, scan, no, no, scan.
Okay.
I got him, I got him, I got him, I got him.
I got him.
I bad, I bad, I bad, bad, bad.
Nice, nice, nice.
Just wait.
Team, team, team, team, team.
Wait, wait, wait, come back, come back.
Team here, team here.
I'm covering I'm gonna cover here Thank you, thank you,
thank you Thank you, thank you Guy here
Careful Okay, I'm good I will go on top I will go on top
Yeah, I'm just, I'll cross There's a guy right here He's
running back Okay, I will go on top Guy, right team here Wow
Oh my god, this team is still Okay I will go close.
I will go close.
I just want to make sure this...
Yeah, this guy is blue.
It's over here.
Oh my god, that's another...
He is so low.
I think our spot is pretty good.
Yeah, it is.
We'll just stay here.
I'm going to loot.
Is there like a 4 by...
Like a 2 by 4?
Oh my god, I have...
I have 11 batteries.
Oh, nice.
Guys, pick it.
Get it.
There's shield cells too for us.
I have too many batteries.
I don't need it.
Me too.
I'm gonna thirst him.
Fuck you.
That's right.
You don't get res.
Is there a guy here or no?
Yeah.
Okay.
Behind the box.
I don't have an... I don't have angle.
Behind here too.
I'm safe right now.
I should be fine.
Okay.
Yeah.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
I'm going to make sure no one's behind us.
No rats.
Rats?
Maybe.
I'm checking here.
I'm checking right now.
No rats.
Only two teams left.
There's a team here and then a team to our left.
And another team there.
We're running, running, running, running.
72.
Oh, so long.
Got him, I got him, I got him.
Nice, nice.
But we can push.
We can push.
I can push.
I can.
Can you cover me?
Okay.
Order.
Thirsted them.
I thirsted them.
Okay.
Order.
Yeah, I'm fine.
We're fine.
Okay.
That team is one person.
That team.
Is a solo.
Team over here.
That team.
Look, look, look, look, look.
Look, look.
They might come to us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, look at this.
Look at this.
Tractor?
Flash, flash, flash, flash!
Oh my god!
I'm in!
Oh, nice!
Oh, he has Krabber.
He has Krabber.
I'm covering.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna give you Q.
Yeah.
It's fine.
I'm good.
I'm just surrendering.
Okay.
I don't know where the second team is.
Tag one.
The second team.
Wait, wait!
Oh, wait, it's solo.
Solo three.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is a solo.
You're solo.
Get out of here.
No, this is all cheap.
I think there's four team.
No, no, I killed... I killed...
Fuck us!
No, I killed one here.
I killed the... he's a solo.
I'm coming over to you?
They're gonna come to us.
We have to focus that team for it.
Okay, I need to...
Yep.
Come here.
We're high ground though.
We have high ground, so we're fine.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
And we also have hammer point.
There.
I feel like he has...
Yeah, we have Hammerport.
If they come close to us, we have Hammerport.
Flash, flash, flash!
This guy!
Ah.
Nice!
Nice.
One down.
I'd focus this team.
This...
Yeah, this team.
Don't kill this so...
Don't kill this guy.
He's a solo.
Below us.
We want this solo to help us.
One guy solo.
Yeah, he didn't thirst him, right?
Oh, I didn't have...
I don't have angle to kill them.
I'm batting, I'm batting.
Don't kill the solo below.
We want him to help us.
Yeah.
Yeah, he's helping us.
We want him to help us kill this team.
Okay.
That's our secret member.
Yeah, he is our teammate.
He is our fourth player.
Kill him!
They want to kill the rat, but we won't let them.
Look at how many heavy ammo do you have right now?
I have 178 here.
I can get 58.
Okay, okay.
Thank you.
Nice.
Yeah, they have to run.
They have to run to us.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot the people on this.
I'm fine.
Safe, safe, safe on me.
Safe on me.
Right here, this guy.
Right here, right here, right here.
Safe on me too.
Blood down, blood down, blood down, crack, crack, crack,
one, one!
Oh, he's so low.
Bloodhound here.
Bloodhound was one.
Oh, no, nice, nice, nice, oh!
Nice, nice.
Oh!
Nice.
Are you hell of us?
We will make you scan.
Okay, crack!
Crash, crash.
Down, down, down.
Nice one.
One crack, one crack.
I will use them.
All right.
Two, two.
It's actually two down there.
It's two.
What the fuck?
I thought it was three.
I thought it was one, but it's two.
That's fine.
What the fuck is wrong with them?
It's the song.
Bro.
Stop
My god, I do it Hammerpoint win I only used hammerpoint once
still Nice I only used it like one time but that's okay we
still won yes that's great that's good i told you that's all
we need oh that's all we need we just need a hammer point
every time we get hammer point it's a champion yeah nice
okay i i find you hammer point yeah yeah it's like lucky
get lucky when we have it yeah yeah yeah you're right we
also have a good position too yeah i knew it i knew it oh in
e oh it's so good oh my god we weren't poor too
part two nope we're not poor no We're not poor, yeah.
Yeah.
I love it when we're not poor.
Me too.
That's us!
Nice, nice, nice.
That's us.
Nice.
Countdown.
Countdown, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Oh, let me see.
Um, I think no one, oh, wait, one team?
One team?
Okay.
I'm not sure, I'm not sure.
Oh, look.
I'm gonna loot inside.
Only one.
One team?
No, no team.
No team?
Okay.
I'm looting inside.
There, there are, there are like four teams in Skyhook.
Alright, we searched Skyhook.
Okay.
We're better done.
Skyhook.
Skyhark.
Oh, well.
Take that.
I'm gonna find Hemlock or, uh, oh wait, I found Hemlock,
nevermind.
Nice.
I found it.
Oh.
Yeah.
I'll take that.
It is hard.
Oh, I don't have that.
Oh, I found one too.
Nevermind.
Yeah.
How am I?
Here is.
If anyone wants that.
Might be...
We did it.
Yeah, oh, parlor!
Oh, nice!
Oh, okay.
You know what?
30-30 was so nice to me.
I'm gonna take it again.
Okay.
Uto, show me...
Uto, this game...
4k.
4k damage.
Uto, I can...
GAMBARE!
Yeah, yeah, pro, remember.
Pro can do it.
Yeah.
You are pro, right?
Are you a liar?
No, no, no, no.
No liar?
Wait, are we going to Skyhook?
No.
Okay.
Alright, 4k.
I believe.
I have key.
Oh yeah, Ki?
Oh, okay.
Let's get a Ki.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go.
Oh, we go walking?
Gotcha.
Okay, let's go walking.
Alright, let's go.
I will go take Yomer.
Alright.
Oh, yeah.
The Harvester?
Yeah.
Alright.
Hammer point.
Whoa.
Hammer boy.
Damn boy.
No.
No?
No, can I?
No!
No, hammer boy.
No.
Wait, wait, fight in front.
I'm gonna go.
Okay, enemy.
Yeah, enemy.
I heard a grenade.
Okay, I will make our...
Oh, I see.
I'm gonna ask you, army.
I'm pretty far.
Be careful.
Oh,
big house.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think we wait.
We wait, we wait, we wait.
Wait for Ditto.
Okay.
Oh, and res too.
Maybe they come to me.
What?
No, no, no, no.
Oh, you're so far.
What do you mean?
They're here.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
What do you mean?
They're racing, they're racing.
Yeah, they're racing.
I'm using it in front of them.
Maybe...
Oh, there's two res!
No, no, no, it's two res!
Two res!
I'm going, I'm going.
Tell me if you need Q.
I'm gonna climb.
Okay, I'm climbing up.
I don't need Q yet.
No Q, no Q.
Two.
Let me know when you crack.
When you crack, I'll call.
Not crack, not, not crack yet.
Okay.
I can...
Okay, I'm waiting.
Waiting too.
Wait, they're white armor!
Cue me, cue me, cue me, cue me, cue me.
Take one.
I don't know where teammates are.
Tommy?
Knock one?
Okay.
Nice one.
Nice.
They were white armor, too.
Oh, wow, wow.
Haha, babies.
Yeah.
Where was he?
Where's one of them?
Oh, wait.
Someone, someone, someone.
I hear someone.
Oh, no, no.
Jump pad.
Tower, tower.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Where?
Are they gonna come to us?
No, no, no, no.
They're here.
Okay.
They're way.
Far, far, far, far, far.
Very far.
I'm good.
I'm gonna heal.
Whoa.
They have man Maggie.
Chill.
Where are the other boxes?
I don't know.
I'm flying.
You ping me some of the boxes?
Wait, they might push.
Okay.
Push.
Yeah, yeah.
They're coming closer.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're here, they're here, they're here.
They're here, here, here.
Careful.
They're inside, they're inside.
Yeah, they're inside.
Uh, third floor?
Yeah, yeah, let's go to the third floor.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I might be dead here.
Oh, I cracked him!
Oh, no!
Oh my god.
Run!
Ditto, run!
You can craft!
Don't be a hero!
No hero time!
Just leave!
Leave!
No!
I'm leaving!
Stop being a hero!
Just run!
Oh, they're a controller.
By the way, they're a controller.
Just leave.
All three of them are a controller.
Go as far as you can!
So they can't aim assist you.
Okay.
Seven feet!
Because it's out of the six feet range.
Okay.
Make sure you're seven feet away.
Oh, you should heal though.
You're so much healed.
Oh, slow way come, slow way come.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Make sure you're seven feet away from the controller
players.
Okay, seven feet.
Yeah.
So you don't get me and get killed.
I wish I was so early.
Why didn't we learn Controlly?
Okay.
Nice.
I think I should...
No, you resus here.
Yeah.
It's zone two.
It's fine.
I don't know if they're gonna come to us.
Okay, they do.
We run.
Okay.
Wait, we're not being cowards.
It's strategy.
Oh, I see them.
I see them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I run.
Run.
Peace, run.
Okay.
Just run.
I saw me.
Just saw me.
If one of us lives, that's okay.
Only one has to live.
What the fuck?
That's okay.
Just one of us has to live.
That's all we need.
Okay, see you.
See you later.
See you later, everybody.
We'll meet again soon.
Okay, I'm safe right now.
Are they chasing?
Nice, nice, nice.
I think they're- Oh, they're chasing me!
They're chasing me!
No, why are you?
What?
How so... Okay, this is a controller prank squad.
Wait, you got a tattoo?
Wait, who did you kill you?
Who killed you?
Who killed you guys?
Oh my god.
This chasing shoots all hard.
You know, when it was worse, they were controller pred
players.
Not only were they pred.
They were controller pred.
Contour paint.
I see.
Yeah.
They were less at the life.
That changes everything.
Guys, it wasn't stream snipers.
They're just good at the game.
They just... We will know if it's stream snipers.
We wouldn't know.
They saw a res and they saw me.
Oh, okay.
Oh.
Oh my god.
They are so thirsty.
They want more kills.
They want to get to Pred again.
Oh, I see.
Is that a Pred team?
Yeah, yeah, that was a Pred team.
Oh, we are Pred too, okay.
Yeah, yeah, but the controller Pred.
that's different oh that's different that's better than the
pro player that's better than pro yeah oh my god yeah like
they they pushed they pushed us so fast holy they pushed us
so fast yeah when I got deleted I I was like, oh.
I was just like, oh, they're just...
Okay.
I didn't want to live in this game.
72 players!
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
This is two lobbies.
Yes.
It's still noon.
Everyone is sleeping.
No, wake up.
You don't sleep when you're grinding rank.
Alright, um, yesterday, um, I watched Chain Virgin Steam.
Yeah.
He had been steaming for 46 hours.
Holy shit.
Oh, good.
Yeah, number one pred.
Yeah.
Fucking crazy.
Yeah, it's not like he's gonna keep it because he has
scrims.
He has pro.
Yeah, yes, yes.
oh you're right yeah so like what's the point he's not i
guess he wants to be the first team like the first player
but he's not gonna keep pred yes because yeah he has to to
do args yeah he has to do lgs there's no way he's gonna
normally people who do rank one pred has like is like
content creator because they don't have time yeah yes they
don't have time for Yeah.
Uto, when are you gonna do PRED?
Come to PRED.
Pratt?
Yeah.
PRED.
Yeah, Uto.
P. Get PRED.
PRED?
Yeah, you.
Get PRED.
No, no, no.
Why not?
No.
Why?
Yeah.
Fake news.
Get PRED.
You can get PRED.
No, I'm not gonna go play.
So easy.
No, we don't have to.
We already got it.
Yeah.
Yeah, but Uto, Uto, Fred.
When, when?
Yeah.
When, Fred.
Today's too big.
Today?
Wow, you told me there's people here!
Not today!
Okay, I give you Q.
I give you Q.
Please, why didn't you tell me there's a team?
Oh, I didn't see it.
I didn't see it.
One team.
Really?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, look at my HP.
That's...
Look at my HP.
Am I lying?
I see him.
He's already here.
Got that one.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Nice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Flesh, flesh, flesh, flesh.
Don't let them rest.
Do you have Q?
Crap?
Low, low.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
One down?
Nice.
Last.
Last down on me.
Time.
That's fucking right.
Nice one.
Yeah.
So Uto, when prayed.
Uto, so good.
Today!
Yeah!
Today?
How many hours?
46 hours?
24.
24 hours?
Yes.
You stream 24 hours?
24 hours?
Dido and I can end stream and you do 24 hours?
What the fuck?
Go!
That's too much.
that's too much no no she will do toy for hours we sleep
okay you didn't tell that you're gonna pay with us yeah you
didn't tell us we we sleep no we sleep yeah you can't sleep
oh yeah i had sleep i feel like dinner now will get prayed
before she gets prayed okay okay oh my god Okay, so so Ditto
doesn't sleep I sleep No, I sleep.
I sleep.
Wait, why do you sleep?
No, no, no, no.
Why?
Wait, this is looted.
Every time.
It's loaded?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm on me.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, on me, on me.
Okay, okay, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
Whoa.
On me.
I can give you I'm good, I'm good, I'm good I'll need it
They're like over here They're here Oh wait, see me, see me
Whoa I'm batting I kept one I'm healing Full heal first
Yeah, you can go here Oh, close, close, close, close Close,
close You have Q, do you have Q?
Yeah, no, no Don't They push you, they push you Yeah, okay
Give me the kill if you can Kill you, kill you, kill you Oh,
fuck, okay.
I'm good I'm so fucked here I got, I got knock one, one,
one, one My one, two, two, two, two, one Last guy here, last
guy here Here, last guy here, yeah, yeah I'm did it, I'm
tätä Oh,
so close Oh, I'm so close.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Hello.
Hello, Aziz.
Oh, he was so low!
Console!
Bitch.
Yeah, power, power, which controller is great.
Bitch, I should boot up my switch.
I should play Apex on my switch right now.
Oh my I still have lower in my PC.
Oh my god.
Bitch.
Beach.
Yeah.
Nice.
Ah.
What?
Okay, I will fall here first before peak.
Oh!
Alright, here we go.
Where are we going?
Countdown?
Okay.
One team!
One team?
Yep.
Yep, yep, yep.
Alright, here will we go?
They're gonna land there, I think.
Oh, they're gonna land here.
Oh, you're landing there?
I'm gonna land here then.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, crap.
Oh, P.S.
Woo!
Okay.
Got my prowler.
Woo!
Wait, is there a team?
Yeah, that's team.
Okay, okay, I'm coming over here.
I'm coming over here.
I have hemlock.
Wait, where are they?
Are you sure?
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
I'm going to... I'm going to Ditto.
Inside the building?
Yeah, you're by yourself, Ditto.
You're by yourself.
Okay.
I'm still good.
They have Kosti.
Kosti can all have Kosti crack.
I'm here.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, I'm pushing.
Help with the help with the Oh, nice.
Where the?
Oh, nice!
Wait, where's the last?
Oh, last on me?
Flash?
Nice!
Nice, nice.
Easy.
Lord Prouler?
Oh, I have to...
Whoa!
What the fuck?
Guys, goodbye everybody.
Why did you...
No sound!
They just showed up!
Only...
The only audio that I can hear is, um...
a gunshot.
No sound.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
We stay easy, please, and they kill us.
And we just die so fast.
There's a curse on it.
Nice, nice, nice.
Go next.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
Alright, okay.
Let's win.
We end on champion.
Okay.
Yeah, we end on champion.
Yeah, and then Uto can keep playing, get Pred.
No!
I watched your stream.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I crashed.
No, I go sleep No, I go sleep My crash No My crash We end on
champion But no, okay Ditto and I End on champion Uto keeps
playing till Pred Uto ends on Pred No, no, no, no, no Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yes No, no, no Yes, yes I believe We believe,
right?
We believe in Pred, Uto Yeah, Uto Show us your Yeah.
One team, one team.
Okay.
Are you down here?
Wait, but what about me?
Yeah, bye, yeah, bye.
You're good?
I'm good, I'm here.
Okay, nice.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I need, I need gun.
I go get gun.
Nice, nice.
Two guys on the left side.
Alright, I'm good.
One guy there.
Alright.
I'm good now.
They're still there.
Okay.
I'm gonna open this then.
I'll wait for you guys.
You don't know if they are leaving.
Are they?
Are they still in?
On me, on me, on me, on me!
Cracked?
I have to back out.
I cracked one though.
I need help.
Okay.
I'm trying to cover you.
Are they coming to me?
Oh.
They're still here.
They're still on bridge.
They come to me.
Yeah, yeah.
They're coming to Ziddo.
We have to help.
Careful.
I'm here.
I'm on bridge.
Wait, where's the third?
There's no third.
Oh, it's Dio?
They're getting inside.
Okay, I'm inside.
Careful.
Help!
Help, Ziddo.
Only two, only two.
Oh, sorry!
It's three, it's three, it's three!
Three, three, it's three!
I'm dead here.
Nice one.
Oh, I cracked him though.
Here, go.
Last one, last one.
Yeah.
Like, no more, no more, no more, no more, no more.
No more shields.
No, it's conduit.
It's conduit.
It was three.
we're so close yeah okay it's okay we end on champion this
is it okay now this time this time okay now i know what to
play nice champion i think we we got two champions three all
right no it was one one it was one right yeah we got one We
got two.
We got...
We got one.
Okay, one.
Look, we're nerfing ourselves.
We're nerfing ourselves.
That's all.
Guys, guys, it's because we were purposely playing bad.
We're...
We pay on 500 feet.
Yeah, this is all on purpose.
Yeah.
Wow A lot of Master here Master Oh, I Oh my god, I got up I
got lost Lost There you go Come on, we can do this We can
win a Not second game This lobby board can We didn't do it
so many laws oh no that's not good one team okay yeah two
team two teams one one one one one one one oh yeah there's a
there's a fuck okay there's a guy behind i'm going to i'm
going to here oh what yeah yes find me oh my god whoa look
at this spot it's fine i'm fine i'm okay i'm okay I'm only
okay I'm worried to help you now Tech one?
All right here It is two, it is two teams, careful Okay, two
team, okay Yeah, yeah, yeah Oh my god, this lobby is so
laggy Maybe we can go, um Train?
Yeah Yeah, okay, we can go Let's go, let's go Oh, it's less
light It's a 10 yard It's the same thing behind us i'm
pretty sure okay okay and we are gonna get sandwich yeah
yeah i don't want to get sandwich at all we also have bad
loot anyway yeah oh my god oh it's not hammer pie is a score
pso this is this is why we've been losing we haven't been
finding hammer points
there you go our luck has not been good to us
Oh, fuck is...
Oh, there's loot here.
What?
That...
Oh, that's...
Oh, that's Leavenend.
Leavenend, careful, careful.
Oh, what?
No, that was me.
Okay.
That sounds like enemies.
Like enemies.
That sounds really like enemies.
Leavenend.
Oh, yeah, scan?
You can?
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay, okay.
I will paint the boss.
Let's see if there's anyone near us.
Oh.
I won't cough yet.
I will keep it for...
Go try to see if we can kill.
Actually, I feel like we're going to get thirded.
I don't know who to fight, actually.
Our loot is so bad.
Yeah, I think we should keep looting.
Yeah.
I mean, we could go here and then see if they're still, if
they started fighting it in fragment.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
That's nice.
Yeah, I'm gonna go over then.
I'm gonna start going to fragment.
Whoa, energy mag.
Oh, you gotta get up here.
Oh my god, that scared me.
Yeah.
That always scares me.
I thought, I feel like I'm being shot.
I know, I know.
Grab the hemlock.
If you found any skull piece, please tell me.
I think...
Two eggs or two.
Skull piercer?
Skull piercer.
I think it was like a long time ago.
Oh no, I got it.
I got it.
Nice.
Okay.
Are they still fighting?
I have no idea.
I'm looting right now.
I'll check.
I think I'm good.
I think I'm good with my loot.
I'm going to go check and I'm going to grab a harvester.
Oh, they're fighting.
They're fighting.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, in front of me.
Oh, no, no, new team.
New team here, too.
New team.
Okay, wait for the new team.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But...
Okay, okay, okay.
Only one, only one.
This guy, there's a guy right here.
Oh, no, no, no.
One team.
One team, yeah.
Over there.
Yeah, there's three teams.
I'm ready.
They stay there.
Yeah, yeah.
And there's a claim here, too.
Under the bridge.
They might fight each other.
Yeah, they're pushing.
They're pushing.
Knock one.
Nice one.
On me, on me.
Almost kicked.
Crack, crack, crack.
This is three.
This is a full team.
It's behind me.
Very weak.
Very low.
Okay.
T-meets here, teammate, teammates.
Oh, I don't have ammo.
No more ammo.
Are you gonna lie?
I think we have to back out.
It's still three teams.
Okay, okay, I gotta go back.
Yeah, come to me, come here.
Okay, okay.
I didn't get a kill.
Full kill, do you guys have heavy?
Wow.
No.
I have heavy, I have heavy.
Okay, I can have some.
Okay, I'll give you one stack.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I give you one stack of G
Thank you for the one stack of three They all left they all
left I think they res too I think we can finish them that
horizon.
Where's that horizon?
I don't I think I think they res her wait my my it doesn't
work Wait, what?
I don't know, maybe it's black.
I'm sorry if we could find them.
Wait, they're fighting again.
Here.
Okay, let's go, let's go.
I think that's them.
Okay.
Cover.
Yeah, they got a knock, I think.
That jump hat here.
Going over.
Oh, grab this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Far, far, far, far, far.
Okay.
Can I shoot?
Oh no, I'm not gonna shoot that.
They're far, they're far, they're far.
Okay.
Tell me if you need my Q.
Wait, oh that's you.
You're so far.
Oh.
Are they alive?
No, they're chasing.
Far?
What the fuck?
They're chasing another team.
They're still running.
Oh, hey, hey, hey, hey.
Enemy, enemy!
Almost kicked.
Oh, I couldn't get him.
I'm gonna climb up.
Oh fuck.
How do I climb up?
Okay, I'm climbing up.
That's okay.
I'm gonna push this one.
Careful, careful.
Carol Dillier, you're by yourself, you're by yourself,
Ditto.
Okay.
Almost Keg.
On Rupert Pop-up.
One team here.
Cracked him.
I'm batting.
Just remember you're by yourself.
Another one.
Okay.
Oh my god, these guys are annoying.
Yeah, I'm looking for you.
Oh, he's so low.
He's fresh.
Far from me.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay, that's my Maggie.
Where did you, where did you kill him?
Oh, my ping.
Okay, I'm ulting.
Okay.
Thank you for the cue.
I give you cue.
I don't see them.
Mommy.
Okay, okay.
He's low, he's low.
Oh my god, he's low.
I'm good I'm going back I'm backing up backing up yeah I
can't I can't Over here I think they rest.
I think they res.
Yeah, they're lanes.
Yeah, because there's mad Maggie Why yeah, I have to heal
nice nice.
I have to heal.
I can't go They might lose again.
Oh, nice nice.
Nice nice Maybe they I think they ran.
Yeah
All right, we rob him.
Nice one.
Good food.
Nice.
Yeah, we should go.
They are still fighting.
In the tunnel.
They are?
Oh, here?
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
There's a team here.
I'm going to go to the one that blew the crack.
Solo, hit the cello.
He's fresh, he fresh.
He don't have armor.
Come over here.
package come on where are you where are you he keeps running
faster faster faster wait he got the fucking wingman too
bitch let's go let's go he's solo oh my Enemy, enemy, enemy,
enemy, enemy, enemy.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, it's a crash.
It's a crash.
I'm gonna cover.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna try to cover.
He's getting shot.
They're getting shot.
Okay.
Try to cover.
Me too, me too.
I'm covering, I'm covering, I'm covering.
Oh, I have to back up.
I can't help.
I kept one.
I have to back up.
I have to back up fully.
I will go to you.
Yeah, yeah.
I can't help her Because there's another team shooting at me
Okay, I'm with her, I'm with her Okay, we're good, we're
good Another team there Another team, yeah, yeah They shot
us We have to go high ground Okay, I have no bat I have
bats, I have bats Okay, actually no, that's my one bat Wait,
there's people here There's people here Wait, what did I
hear?
What?
Wait, yeah, they're rising!
You're rising!
Below us!
Yeah!
Right here.
I'm not coming...
I'm gonna kill first.
I'm gonna make sure no team runs into us.
They have a hammer point!
They have a hammer point.
Yeah, but...
Okay.
I'm gonna check for...
They're there too!
There is two!
Okay.
Scan, scan, scan.
I'm gonna...
Climbing up?
Yep.
Climbing up!
where where are they oh no i'll do it on the one god damn it
my all oh my god they're so far
okay oh my god oh my god we can't be so fast why are you
ready i need heavy ammo i don't have okay let's loot let's
loot oh my god we can't we can't cute one i i make like um
thousand damage but i have no oh my god they keep lying i
know fucking bitch okay in front of me in front of me okay
okay two teams two teams two teams okay be careful be
careful i'm gonna get some loot yeah
why well killed oh nice one there's another team here in
front of me i was trying to loot this guy
That's fucking right.
You thought you could run.
Oh my god, he's so rich.
Do you need heavy?
Yes.
Yeah, he's rich.
Actually, I'm going to grab the prowler then.
Oh, nice.
Nice kill.
Yeah.
Careful, careful.
They have to come to us.
They're not in zone.
They're right below us.
I'm going to shoot below.
Okay.
Right here?
Right there, right there.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
I'm in there.
Behind this rock, behind this rock.
Wait, his teammates are right here.
What?
Is that the same team?
Wait, what?
That's another team.
Oh, shit.
Woo!
Yeah, yeah, careful, careful, careful.
Nice, nice.
No, I don't want, I don't want, I don't want.
I don't want.
Careful.
We're not in zone.
I need a heal.
I don't have, I only have small meds.
Only small meds.
Crack one.
Oh.
I'm pushing, I'm pushing.
I'm gonna push.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, I have a point!
I'm going, I'm going, I'm coming, I'm coming.
Down, down, down.
Nice.
Nice job.
Okay, that might- Oh!
Do you have Q?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, I have Q.
Oh yeah.
Give me two.
Crack, crack, crack.
No, crack.
26?
I need a bat.
Good, I'm good.
Do you thirst him?
I'm gonna thirst him.
Where's the hammer point?
Where is it?
Oh, they're so poor.
No, you guys didn't have it.
What the point?
Where was it?
Oh, we have to go.
We have to go.
Do you have redeploy or no?
Oh, I have I have hit here.
Enemy here.
What was in that?
I don't remember.
Alright.
We have to go.
Wait, we can actually go here.
Do you want to go tunnels?
Yeah.
Yeah, we can go tunnels.
Yeah, we can go tunnel, tunnel.
Come now.
Alright.
We should be.
One team there.
Yeah, let's just stay in tunnel.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't believe the guy we didn't kill was the one with the
hammer point.
I'm so sad.
I'm so fucking sad.
Of course!
Of course.
I will look left.
Okay, there's no one.
Maybe we can get...
Can we get above?
On top.
I can go here.
Okay, okay.
They're fighting each other.
I don't have battery.
But I have my Q.
I'm gonna scout.
One, one fish.
One fish there.
I know.
I want to make sure we don't get flanks.
Okay.
Woo.
They have two, they have two, they have two.
Okay.
Behind the line.
Can you scan back here, though?
Can you scan?
Yeah, yeah, scan.
Yeah, I knew it.
I knew there was people there.
Nice.
I remember there was a fight there or something.
Okay, one, two, and another team.
I'm not sure where are they.
So low here, I think.
Right here?
Lay slow.
I don't have angle.
Okay?
No angle.
Okay, me too.
You guys, you guys, you guys wash here.
I will wash our back.
Oh my god.
Okay, I need a heal.
I want to make sure the team to my left doesn't push us.
Yeah, you make sure the team...
Yeah, solo here.
Yeah, he has red armor.
Crack.
Nice.
You get the solo?
I hear the solo here.
Do you guys have light ammo?
Oh.
No, no, they're not.
There's a solar light.
Focus here.
Focus this guy.
By himself.
Behind this rock.
I'm going back.
Yeah, yeah.
Someone...
Okay, this is really risky.
Here, this guy.
Oh, I don't have a lot of ammo left.
I can't give you heavy ammo.
This is not zone.
Okay.
Do you want heavy ammo?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
all right never mind i can't shoot anymore i can't shoot
anymore we're still in zone but this team is i only have
short range wait they're res what who resed maybe that team
oh i guess so oh this team yeah oh my god okay this team is
in zone I don't want this team to push us.
I'm just gonna wait.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna wait.
I don't- I only have close range.
Okay.
What are you using right now?
Carbine, prowler.
I don't have light, so I'll just- I have prowler.
Careful, careful!
Yeah, I'll cover, I'll cover.
Thank you.
Oh, they're right below me.
They're queued below us.
Okay.
Be careful, they're his allies.
They're right below me.
Yeah, yeah, right here.
I'm looking at climb up.
I can't get any anger.
I'm making sure they don't climb up.
This team on our left, this team has to come to us.
Or this team has to rotate first.
Careful, Ditto.
They might rush you.
Okay, okay, okay.
They might try and rush you.
I think we should be like a bit closer.
Yeah.
1 o'clock.
Come here, come here!
Here!
Here.
Careful, Ditto.
Yeah, don't let them push up.
Yeah, hold that away.
Just make force...
Well, I won't force them to go this way.
That's the one guy here.
Yeah, I'm looking at the portal.
I'm looking at the portal so they don't push.
Y'all up, guys?
Okay.
One, one keg.
Can I zoom?
Yeah.
Can you scan?
Yes, scan.
I got the bag.
Oh, okay.
Oh, no, this is bad.
There's so many people on us.
Oh, my God.
There's a guy team above us.
I'm batting.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Play slow.
Oh, what the fuck?
No!
Oh, my God.
Wait, they all pushed us in the head.
Holy shit.
So close.
Yeah.
I thought they would push each other, but they put, like...
They didn't push.
They did.
They knocked, like, one, and then they, like, chilled.
They knocked one and chilled.
Yeah, they knocked one and was like, never mind.
Nice ride, this is...
Come on, we need that champion!
It just sucked I had zero ammo, my other gun.
No ammo.
Okay, let's see.
I wanna try...
I'm gonna try Bangalore.
Okay.
And spending a lot of time.
There we go.
We can get...
We can get champion.
We can do it.
Champion number two.
Champion number two, okay.
Yeah, no sleep until champion.
And then...
Uto no sleep until Fred.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah...
We sleep, we go sleep.
We wake up and then...
No!
And then Uto's still playing.
and then we help her and then we get champion and then we go
sleep again and then utaki and then uta keeps going
i believe no doki no sleep did no sleep no no no i'm so
sleepy i'm so Sleepy.
Oh, me too.
Oh.
Yeah, I'm so sleepy.
I can't say I can't say it anymore.
But Uto, you're not sleepy.
You're not sleepy.
I'm sleepy.
No, no, no.
Wait, what time?
No!
Oh my gosh!
No, I'm sleepy.
Wait, what time is it in Japan?
What time?
What time, Uto?
Sleepy.
You're sleepy?
Yeah.
And you're sleepy?
Oh my god.
What?
When you wake up?
Don't let me die.
I'm coming back.
What?
I crashed.
I crashed, yes.
Don't let me die.
There's no one there.
Don't, don't worry.
You're not gonna die.
No team, no team.
Oh, let me die.
I'll be very angry.
You won't like you when I'm angry.
Oh my god, nice.
Ah, okay, okay.
Let's see.
Got my alternator.
Do you want alternator?
No, I found an alternator.
Oh, I need...
I want...
Uh...
I'm good with my loader, actually.
Let me know you find Disruptor.
Oh, wait, there's Prowler.
You want Prowler?
No.
I hope him won't.
You know what?
I'm gonna go run.
Double heavy!
Double heavy?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I'm crazy.
I know that.
Crazy.
Okay, we're all crazy.
We play apex.
We're crazy.
But I'm not crazy.
Yes, you are.
You're the craziest.
Uto, is Ditto crazy?
Crazy.
Yeah, is Ditto crazy?
No, no, no, no.
Oto is crazy.
Yes, yes.
Crazy, so crazy.
Number one crazy.
Crazy.
Crazy!
Fuck you, though.
What?
Fuck you!
There's a blue backpack here.
I'm afraid, okay?
Oh, that's mine!
That's mine!
Oh shit, I'm Bangalore.
I tried to jump.
I was like...
I almost jumped off.
All right, I got my double heavy Nice double heavy Oh, I got
it Oh, another boat back here Hammer point I found hammer
point Nice, okay, okay I need, I need I need, I need, I need
It's win, it's win time Okay, we go, go, go, go I found I
found re and and fucking hammer this is it nice this is it i
have six i have six badly anyone wanted yeah yeah i what the
fuck i have one
okay all right give me i'm poor okay i okay i'm here two me
beat me beat me mama mama beat me mama no uto is uto is
grandma no grandma so old oh so old baby
mama grandma oh fighting the sky okay okay sky hook sky hook
sky hook yeah
finally here another one I'm good yoink okay yoink let's not
yeah yeah let's go let's go from back yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah they don't know they don't know they don't they
don't wash they don't wash their back yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah they're so stupid okay wait I'm gonna go from Yeah, you
guys go from top, I'll go from bottom.
Because you know when it's done, the door is open.
Okay, you two go top.
Also, I want to loot this too.
They don't know, they don't know, they don't know, they
don't know.
They don't know.
I'm going to wait until it finishes.
Are you shooting?
Are you shooting them?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I cracked one, I cracked one.
Wait, where are they?
I can't... I can't too.
I can't too.
I down too.
Only one guy there.
Yeah, the last guy ran.
Oh!
Okay.
Give me a sec!
I'm fighting my demons.
I'm fighting my demons just now.
You good?
Yeah, I'm okay.
Oh, look.
All ours.
I got only one kill.
Yeah, I got...
Yeah, the guy ran.
Scan?
Maybe they're leaving.
Why is she scanned?
Oh my, oh, there's a scan here.
No, I got so cute.
I got so cute.
I'm gonna...
Oh, it's an enemy!
Where?
Oh yeah, there.
I'm coming over.
I... Oh, Otto!
No!
Careful!
Oto, wait!
I got the heal.
I'm trying...
Oh, I don't see.
Scan?
They run, I think.
Yeah, they run, they run.
They're okay.
I want, um...
I thought...
Kill.
We can...
We can redeploy.
No redeploy?
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Just redeploy.
Okay.
I know there was a scan.
There might be a team here, I think.
Okay.
Are you here first?
Goodbye, see you later.
Sayonara.
Goodbye.
Are you good there?
Yeah, save, save.
Okay, okay.
Let's save.
I want heal.
Wait, do I have med kit?
I have the full heal for you.
Okay, do you need med kit?
I don't have it Here I'm using signage I have an extra med
kit for you Okay There's a team here I don't know where they
are But I saw like a package come down Oh we have to go to
zone Okay I'm gonna run to zone Careful, careful Okay, okay
Maybe we can um Scan Scan the enemy first Yeah, yeah Locate
Yeah Landslide Yeah Put the scan.
Okay.
Put the scan just die.
Oh my gosh, I have fucking so many heavy ammo.
Oh no, I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna craft.
I'm not gonna craft.
Oh shit, hey, there's two teams here.
I think we should go to zone.
We should go to zone.
Oh, go to zone?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's call, let's go.
Because like, we might get here and here.
Yeah.
Nice.
I'm gonna get to high ground.
One team down.
Yeah, there's two teams here.
Maybe we can play here.
Yeah, I want to play here, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Enemy here.
Okay, one team.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Oh, what?
How did they get here?
Don't look at me.
Oh.
Climbing.
You didn't see me.
Get in!
He's one of me!
Flash, flash, flash!
Oh, shit!
He looked at me!
I can't.
I can't do anything.
You have to heal.
I have to heal.
Careful.
There might be a team behind us, so careful.
Yeah, another squad shooting.
I'm gonna look behind us.
Yeah, yeah, team behind us.
Team behind us.
I'm gonna cover.
I'm trying to cover.
I'm trying to make sure they don't run to us.
I want them to go low ground.
Wait, oh my god!
There's so many teams!
I'm making sure this team...
We can't get inside first if we...
I think we don't have...
Careful?
Here, I kept one.
Two, two there, two there.
Both of us.
Yeah, I'm looking at the one.
Oh, shit!
I'm down!
Stop, goodbye!
I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay!
I'm okay!
Kill, kill, kill, kill!
I walked backwards!
It's okay.
I'm okay, I'm okay.
Nothing bad has happened to me.
It's okay.
They pushed me, they pushed me, they pushed me.
Come to me, Delir.
I'm gonna smoke.
I'm gonna smoke you.
I can't.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna try to smoke you.
Oh, we can't help you, actually.
No, you're way too far.
Oh, that's another team!
That's so unlucky.
You're way too far from us.
Yes.
Yeah, I fell down and- I'm trying to get to you, but how?
Oh, they have E1-8.
Careful.
Yeah, I'm batting.
Wait.
Okay.
Do you have redeploy?
What the- Yeah, redeploy, right?
Okay, I want back up.
I want to back up.
They're gonna walk up.
There's three.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
That's them.
Oh, behind us.
That's not good for us.
They might push.
Yeah, they're pushing.
They're pushing.
Back up, back up.
Yeah, I might die.
Run, just run, just run.
Okay, okay.
I shouldn't...
No!
I shouldn't!
Two team inside the arena for...
Three, three.
Three?
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Goodbye, see you later.
Sayonara.
You can carve us.
Oh my god, they...
They don't know, they don't know, they don't know.
If they know, they should.
Are you fucking...
No!
If they don't know they're cheating.
How?
It is new.
How come I know?
Well, I guess they're cheating!
How did you know?
They got changed me so hard.
If they don't know they're cheating.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
such good game sense how did they know
oh i'm gonna eat hamburger today hamburger hamburger Today
What type?
Truffle?
Torifl?
And mushroom?
Truffle?
Maximum?
Truffle, so...
Truffle?
Eh, like, like, you know, like, notified- Treefu?
Oh, treefu.
Yeah.
Turifle.
Truffle?
Truffle.
Tuffle
Tuffle Tuffle Tuffle Tuffle Yeah, quinoca Mushroom Tuffle
Tuffle Tuffle Tuffle Wow
Jogi, do you like Tuffle?
Huh?
One party.
She's dead.
Doki, wake up.
Oh, I found hammer point.
If you want hammer point, tell me, tell me, wake up, wake
up.
Oh, she's discinating.
She's dead.
Dead.
I'm back but I crashed!
Okay, okay, nice time!
I'm back!
Wait, I have hammer part two.
I have hammer part two.
Wait, there's enemy?
Enemy.
Wait.
R4D.
Okay, okay, protect me.
I'm important.
Oh, me, oh, me.
Protect me.
What almost cash?
I believe in all of you.
You guys can do it.
You're so good at the games.
Don't die.
I have no guns.
Gas, gas, gas, gas.
One K?
Okay, I'm coming back.
K?
I'm here!
Oh my god, there's a god.
Wait, wait, where is this?
They're trying to push us?
Where's the hammer?
Oh my god, they are.
Yep.
So close, so close.
They're on the side?
They're coming over, they're coming over.
I'm gonna try and grab a gun.
Alright, triple sniper, let's go.
Wait, what?
Wait, there's another...
Yeah, I'm getting shot by a different angle.
One, one guy, one guy so far.
So, solo.
Oh, I'm going to...
Okay, I'm going to Udo.
No, no, no, no.
Nice, nice, where are you?
Come here?
Nice.
Is there it?
Oh, my God, please give me a different gun.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Above us, above us.
Please.
Above us?
Yeah, I'm gonna remember.
Okay, okay.
They fall.
They drop down.
Not yet, not yet.
Oh, they scan me?
I'm looking.
Scan them.
Crack one?
Nice.
Wait, army?
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
Oh, shit.
Second fall.
One, one, one, one!
Where is he?
How many?
Nice, he was one.
Nice, nice.
Look at that.
Nothing to worry about.
Nothing to worry.
Easy, easy, easy.
Oh my god.
I was not scared.
Wait, where's the hammer point?
Oh my god, nice.
How about here?
I saw it down here.
What?
Where did it go?
Oh, here, here, here, here, here, here.
Oh my god, okay, this is it.
This is it.
We win.
Okay.
Do you have a gun?
There's a disruptor here.
Yeah, I have a vault in the flat line.
Okay.
Here on R.E.
Oh, nice.
Let's see.
Okay.
Let me know you guys find a 30-30.
30-30, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna loot the other side.
Okay.
I'm looking for a car or a powder.
I need 30-30.
Oh, there's a powder there.
Oh, nice.
Bucky present.
Oh.
Oh, there's a 30-32.
Happy birthday.
Oh, I don't need it.
I found another one.
I'm returning your birthday.
present.
Oh, I'm gonna head to zone.
I don't have enough meds.
I should have gone.
Ah!
Goodbye, everybody.
No.
No powder.
Nice.
I found a digi too.
Here.
There's a lot of prowlers.
Okay.
Okay, we use powder and iron.
one yeah parallel 301 is all right i need a scope two x or
two three or two four okay the is a scope
hello yeah it's empty still trying to of fun.
I'm trying to find a scope.
My 30-30 is naked.
So cold.
Oh,
fragment?
Enemy?
Okay, fragment, okay.
Uh, okay.
Oh, scope!
Oh, nice!
Nice one.
Okay, I'm gonna go to fragment.
Oh.
All right.
I go to fragment.
With my...
My 30-30 is not naked anymore.
Oh, I need...
Oh, nice.
Yeah, I needed that.
I don't hear gunshots anymore.
Me too.
I feel like...
Do you guys need battery?
Nah, I have five.
I have five.
Me too.
We're rich now.
Okay, we'll never be poor again!
Yeah, you need battery?
Okay, I'll get it.
I'll go.
There's a...
Thank you.
Where the fuck is this team?
I'm scared we're gonna run into a team.
Okay.
I'm so scared.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll take hiding down.
Oh, whoa!
Do we run?
Do we leave her?
Okay, we leave her.
We leave.
Yeah!
Wait.
Sorry.
Goodbye.
Wait, wait, wait.
See ya.
See ya later.
Bye.
Here we go.
Skyhook?
Yeah, we can.
Um, meet you on the other side of the sky.
hook if one of us dies you can what the other can just craft
this okay i hope it's you so i can keep my hammer point
who's gonna be the lucky one i you seriously you seriously
why would it be me okay no uto's the most unlucky one why
would it be me and why would it be me I'll go craft, you go,
Rez.
It seems like there's no one here.
I will go grab armor first.
All right, I got her.
Oh, we're lucky.
We have good luck.
Oh, nice.
It's Uto.
That's unlucky.
What if I got here, by the way?
Unlucky.
She is the unlucky one.
Nice.
See, nothing to worry about.
Thank you.
I think we should...
We should go here.
Okay, I have to cover Uta first.
She'll be fine.
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, you don't need to cover her.
She'll be okay.
She is strong.
She's a pro.
Oh, you're right.
She have a pro move.
Yeah, oh, you scanned this too.
You won't get shot at, Uto.
You're so lucky.
Okay, okay.
Uto, you can scan this.
Don't worry.
I'll stand in front.
Nice, nice, nice.
Yeah, you're so lucky.
Oh, we're so lucky.
Yeah.
Is that you?
Okay, I was gonna be like, who is that?
Me, me, me.
It's me.
Okay.
I'm gonna make sure no one... I'm gonna...
I'm looking this way.
Okay.
I, really like.
Alright, Uto.
Scan.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I'm blocking you.
Oh, what the fuck?
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Uto, go, go, go.
Oh, my God, God.
No, my.
Uto, go kill!
We'll wait here!
Why not?
Yeah, we should, yeah.
I feel like everybody's gonna run here.
So we should go here.
That'll be fine, Uto.
Whoa!
Can we go first?
Yeah, we should go now.
We should go now.
Okay, Uto, come, come.
Okay.
Okay, this place is free.
Yeah, yeah, it's so free.
Are we gonna go here first?
Alright, you're gonna go high ground?
Okay, wait, oh wait, yeah, why the fuck am I going low
ground?
We can stay on high ground.
I'm a little silly right now.
Are we gonna stay here or go inside the link first?
I feel like...
No, we can go stay up.
Because no one's gonna contest us on our side.
I feel like.
Wait, who's...
What's the...
Oh, there he is.
Where is the solo?
Oh, me.
Wait, he's gonna res.
He's soloed.
No!
He got it off!
The stupid solo!
He actually got it off.
Okay.
He has to come to us.
Yeah, he does.
There's no cover here.
too there is actually never mind here let's hit this one
here two two two two two two no because we saw him as a solo
remember we should have made oto kill him yeah i'm sorry i
told you guys i knew it oh crack crack crack crack can i
highlight him behind the car oh so much They will get
killed.
I don't think so.
No, they're safe here.
Okay, I will watch our back.
Yeah, you watch the other side.
Yeah, I want to make sure.
Yeah, we can just go here later.
I don't want this team to run on us.
Are you watch here?
I want him to run to leave us.
Okay.
Oh yeah, they're running, they're running, yeah.
Yeah, leave.
territory.
Okay, I'm coming over.
Okay.
How much does this hurt?
Let's go.
Let's go inside the lane.
Yeah.
This doesn't hurt too much.
I'm okay.
Okay.
I dropped down.
Yay!
I'm gonna make sure no team runs behind us.
Okay.
Oh no!
What?
One team.
One?
What?
How do you change?
Okay, goodbye, diddo.
Goodbye.
Oh my god.
What the heck?
Okay.
See you later.
Goodbye.
Let's see.
I'm trying to figure out.
It's a scene.
Goodbye.
It was camping.
Maybe you can grab my...
No.
There is no way.
That's not good.
Yeah.
I don't think anybody can grab that.
Fuck this!
You should have stayed with us, dido?
No.
You should have stayed with us.
We can't.
Hey, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Craft, craft, craft, craft.
Craft, craft.
I'll smoke, I'll smoke.
You lied to me.
I smoked.
Go!
Okay, okay, okay.
Go.
Don't worry, I'll save you.
Yeah, I smoked.
I smoked all the way back.
I smoked.
Oh, oh, you're rising here.
Okay, I didn't realize you have respawn.
One team, one team.
One team helped Duel.
Okay.
Okay, we're...
This is safe?
Okay, that's cool.
I didn't realize this was safe.
yeah it's safe i'm gonna go kill that bangalore i don't
think any i don't think you're gonna be killing anybody wait
wait what okay okay okay okay i'm here ready ready three two
okay okay nice nice my love i shot you i shot you instead
But there's me, bro.
You scared me.
Oh my gosh.
We're fine.
No, don't.
I need...
Look, see?
You're not baby anymore.
I'm not baby, but I need sale and shoe and a lot of thing.
We got everything we need.
We're okay.
Ooh, Krabber.
Careful.
Get a headshot.
Oh, shit.
We're not in zones.
guys!
We're not in zone.
Wait.
Do you think?
I don't think we can get in time.
But, I'm gonna try.
We can, we can.
But where do we go?
I don't know.
Oh, how about that?
We can, we can, we can.
I can't upgrade my perk this game.
This is scary.
Are you going here?
Okay, all right, you guys go.
Nice to smoke.
Guys, nice.
Inside the lane.
Here.
Yeah, I'm good.
I'm good.
Oh my god, I don't like this stone.
Oh, this is a...
Careful, careful, guys.
Are you right?
whoa i kept one yeah to my right to my right careful right
right side right side careful careful look at right okay
okay yeah i don't have i don't have needs i have no names
why are you smoking me killed them oh they died to ring
this is scary Oh my god.
Fuck off!
They got us gone.
Wow, wow, wow.
Fuck off!
Woohoo!
Whoa, Kodi.
Do you have ult?
No, 90, 90.
90%.
Okay, I got the ult to it then, but I don't know how to ult
this.
I think alt right, alt right so they don't run to us.
Okay.
Oh, they ult us.
They ult us.
Fine.
Can you smoke them?
Here.
I do.
I smoke this area.
Okay.
Let's go here.
I have ulting left.
I'm ulting left.
I am ulting left.
You alt right?
I'll alt left.
Okay.
I'm okay.
I should have ulted right.
Oh my god.
I can't go.
My ult.
I can't run.
I'm not going on the left side.
Oh my god.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
I'm fucked.
I'm dead.
I'm not gonna die.
You're not gonna die.
Really?
I feel dead.
Believe.
Okay.
You're surviving.
To my right, to my right, careful to my right, to my right,
to my right.
I knocked one, I knocked one.
Let me know who you craft.
What?
They're over here!
Careful, careful, careful, careful, careful.
Nice.
I'm gonna give you ice去.
Armour swap, armour swap, armour swap.
Just armour swap, don't mind me.
Last two, team, last team.
I'm covering.
Oh my god The quaver
I didn't believe That bull had wingy Oh my What the fuck
happened?
I got quavered And then that wingman headshot I got shut
down so hard Oh my god It's because I didn't believe It's
because I didn't fucking believe
Why did I stop believing?
You didn't believe so you died?
Yeah, I didn't believe enough.
Oh my god.
Living Nant.
I didn't believe hard enough.
My bad.
I tried.
We did our best.
We tried our best.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, we were so close to champion And then all of them
was like No fuck you I should have altered right I should
have altered right God damn it
I can't believe it We're so close Yeah, we were so close
Champion champion this is it this game this game will be
champion i believe oh my god we've been playing for four
hours oh my god yeah we've been playing for four hours
oh my god bro fuck those guys
how dare they that's fucked up they won't let us
sleep right I want to know raise a champion team let's go
land on them yeah where are you where are you where are you
I'm gonna land on you and beat you up I'm gonna be like come
come count down come count down oh my god yeah That's
fucking right.
Come to downtown.
Release fists.
Yes.
Nice one.
Oh.
Oh, fuck!
What happened?
Oh, you fell?
I fell to the lava.
Nice.
Oh, wow.
Let me see.
This is a champion comp.
Oh, that's a... Yeah, that's champion comp.
Yeah, champion comp.
I hear Skyhook.
Skyhook.
Okay.
I'm heading over to Skyhook.
I'm heading over to Uto.
Okay.
This is it.
This is the run.
Do they push Uto?
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
She's just existing.
I push.
You push?
Okay, go.
I'll push.
Go!
Yeah!
Okay,
battery won, but...
Oh, I'll take that.
Alright, go...
Go save Uto.
Yeah, they're fighting, they're fighting.
Yeah, we have to go fast before they finish.
Okay.
Go faster.
Yeah.
Uto, go faster.
Uto go faster.
Go faster, Utho.
Greshu, Greshu.
Oh, he's so low!
Yeah!
Why did you kill him?
If he's so low, he should have been dead.
Wait, where's the other team?
I make him low.
It's a gun.
Low?
Yeah.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
I hit 10 on him.
It did my job.
Oh, I want a team there.
Yeah, they ran.
They don't fight each other.
Why?
What the fuck?
Come on!
Just gun and run!
Yeah!
I think they're there.
Yeah, they did.
They were so scared.
Oh, wait.
Left side?
Here.
And Nick Crows, yeah.
He's solo.
Teammate, teammate here.
Teammate low, team low!
I got it.
Knocked him, knocked him, knocked him.
Go, go, go.
Nice one.
I can't give you Q.
Yeah.
Finish him.
Oh, they ran.
They ran.
Okay.
On the rooftop.
One more point.
Hammer point!
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm gonna...
Oh, you're YouTube, too?
Hello, YouTube.
Whoops.
That scared me.
Be careful of all of us.
Oh, wait, what?
Yeah, I saw him.
Yeah, yeah, I just saw.
Wait, there's two teams, two teams!
Two teams!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
I feel like we have to...
Where are they?
We're fighting each other, we're fighting each other.
We can...
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
We don't have to worry too much.
Clash?
On me, on me, on me!
Yeah, thank you.
I'm with you, I'm with you.
Oh no.
Low, low, low, low, low, low, low, low.
Low, low, low, low.
Here, here, here, here, here, here, here.
I got him.
Nice, nice, nice.
Help, help, help.
Behind you, behind you, behind you.
Crack.
Kill yourself first.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm trying.
Nice, nice, nice.
Another team.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Armor swap, armor swap.
Armor swap.
Yeah, I'm gonna swap.
I'm gonna swap.
Someone look at him.
Can someone look?
Yes, can.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna heal.
I can go.
What is going on?
I'm trying to get ammo.
First floor?
My first floor?
Oh, no.
Cheese.
Wait, where's his teammate?
Maybe run away, I think.
Oh.
Nice.
Uh, I only have syringes.
Yeah.
Yeah, here's men.
Alright, nice.
Yay!
Okay.
I will throw this one Hmm, don't run Let's see, I'm running
Carbine, oh, vault Okay Oh shit Whoops They don't have
elapsed though I can get energy, like 24 I mean heavy, heavy
Yeah, no heavy, yeah They don't have heavy Let's go.
Let's go from their side.
Yeah, I'm good.
Oh, their side?
Yeah.
We have to heal.
Wow.
Nice.
We're so healthy.
No, my hammer...
I don't know where the hammer point was.
I can't remember.
Uto found it Yeah, and then I didn't pick it up We're not
getting champion No No We can We can I'm lazy I'll see you
guys later I don't want to run anymore The fighting there
Careful, left side Where?
Oh, they won't see me Wait, wait Oh, if I die You're welcome
Okay Okay, if I die, we lay loose.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
What?
She doesn't have...
Oh, no more meds?
Okay.
We should go...
Just go here.
But they'll run before, because we don't have meds.
Okay, I only have signage.
No battery.
I'm just running.
I only have three syringes left.
Make sure I have only two.
Oh, someone died to ring.
I think we should go inside the lane.
Yeah, yeah, that's what I'm trying.
I want to go from...
Oh, wait, someone's in the...
Ignore.
Don't look at them.
Okay, okay.
Just run.
You don't have meds.
They also saw us.
Yeah, but they're not shooting.
So they're pretending they didn't see us.
Yeah, that means they don't have loot.
Yeah, so we don't so we leave.
We don't have surrogate Okay, okay.
Okay.
I have three surrogates.
Utu has zero, but she's not going to live We fight with
sale.
There's people here.
Yeah, okay.
Run.
Okay.
Um, go tunnel, go tunnel go tunnel Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
careful careful that might feel at all camping i need
syringes where are the syringes my syringes
nice no okay no i'm not gonna take it i know i know you need
it oh i got my signage there's signage another signage here
yeah i'm good i have my Serenus.
Uto needs it.
There's a team in front!
Oh shit!
Okay.
Thank you, thank you.
Team in front, team in front, team in front.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Ami?
Okay, I will give you...
No, it's gone.
Oh fuck!
Oh my god.
I'm gonna give you a...
Ah, maybe.
I give it to...
Ami?
Oh!
Okay!
Which one?
Free kill!
Oh, free kill!
Nice!
Free kill.
Nice.
Oh.
There's another body.
Another body.
So many parts.
You're here.
Have a bag, two of a bag.
Yeah, yeah, that's fine.
That's the one team.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're like all the way there.
We can...
We can go forward.
Like...
Yeah.
Maybe I can go...
Wait, I hear...
Peacekeeper.
This is... This is zone.
This is zone.
Okay, let's...
Yeah.
Let's go there.
It's fine.
I love free kills.
Yeah, they res this guy and then left him to die.
He has no gun!
Wait, he was actually AFK.
Okay, okay.
This man has zero guns.
How poor.
That poor man.
Here, here's syringes.
Okay, nobody here.
again
oh my gosh this is too far for me check if i'm gonna check
if anyone stop okay stop we have we gotta go we have to go
yeah okay it's very risky there's an it's very risky but we
could go through a tunnel that one team on the beach Yeah,
but there's a team here, too.
Hey, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, I see it here, too.
This is scary.
Where do we go?
I don't have redeploy.
They're crossing?
Oh, now they know.
Wait, I have all.
I have all.
Okay.
I'll all here.
I'm all here.
Yeah, yeah, but they have to run.
They have to run then.
And then we can walk up here.
Yeah, we can walk up.
It's time to walk up.
Okay, nice.
Alright, let's see if there's anyone above us!
Oh, there's people here.
I- I can't think of anyone above us.
Yeah, we're fine, we're fine.
But there's a team here though.
Oh, I missed.
Oh, I missed every shot.
Nice.
Me too.
I'm gonna smoke them.
It's too embarrassing now.
It's too embarrassing.
Wait, they're rising.
Wait, no, I gave them a smoke so they can res!
Oh, that's another squad?
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Don't- No!
I gave them a smoke for their fucking res!
We gotta go inside.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where do we want to go though?
You gotta figure out soon.
Maybe we land our order.
share we have to i'm smoking okay oh fuck okay we have to go
then okay bye oh oh oh okay nice nice oh there's a team in
front do you guys have more syringes i have two i have four
i can't give you one we have to be careful because they're
gonna have they have high ground yeah yeah i'm watching
watching no they they're fighting with me with another team
oh yeah you can be careful be careful check one yeah nice
i'm looking above i'm gonna look above us yeah they're
fighting with another team i mean maybe we can go go to that
um that that building okay you guys i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna look real fast if i die i die okay okay okay I die, I
die.
I believe in you two.
And I can watch you two play.
You can come here.
Goodbye.
I'm gonna burn.
It's fine.
I'm good.
Okay.
This building, this building.
Okay, okay, okay.
There's no one.
It's free.
All right, all right.
I'm going over.
Wow, they're fighting too.
Crazy they're fucking wait.
There's people behind us You're fucking crazy Husbiter
pusbiter where ping ping oh, they're down down down.
They go third.
They go third Everyone left everyone left the yeah everyone
left us Everyone just wants to I want fight this everyone
wants to fight this.
I will go this house.
Yeah, yeah, just we'll cross I'm gonna I'm looking here I'm
looking here Okay They're pushing Are they pushing Army army
No Here Behind this Behind this there's a Army army They're
pushing They're planning on pushing How many people?
Two teams One behind this box And one here I give you I give
you Crack one Careful this box This box There's a team, too.
There's a guy right here.
Yeah, this guy can come.
Okay, okay.
Jesus.
What?
No!
Okay, they might push.
They might push.
Can you guys get a res?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
They're pushing.
They're pushing, pushing, pushing.
Team Baha.
Careful.
They're full pushing.
Crank.
Oh, goodbye.
If I did us.
I got, what the fuck?
What?
One, two, three, four, five headshots in a row.
Yeah, from three different, from two different people.
I was like, how did I die so fast?
Oh my god.
Five different headshots.
Wow.
NCNT Five-page shots That's a lot That is way too many
Headshots Oh my god Oh
Oh my god Please just You know what It's Maybe I just need
to be rev We won on Rev.
We won on Rev.
Maybe I just need to be Rev.
You're right.
This is it.
Here we go.
We got this.
I believe.
We believe.
Yeah.
Wow.
Well, you can win.
I believe in us.
Sure.
We can win.
Uto IGL us.
If you IGL us, we will win.
Okay, okay, okay.
We're just...
Just be sleepy.
We're just missing your IGL.
Yeah.
Please IGL us.
Oh, one team, one team.
They have like...
Wait, I don't know Pathfinder with default skin It's okay.
We can do this.
I believe I'm not scared.
Oh shit.
I have a charm.
Fuck!
What happened?
Oh, what happened?
I'm gonna die Whoa, no, you're not.
You're fine.
I'm watching.
I'm good.
No, no, they're running.
They're running Oh, okay.
Nice.
You're okay.
They're scared They saw you and they got scared because I'm
better.
Yeah, yeah, Yeah, when you're running away, too.
You're so scary.
Oh, my!
What happened?
I saw you're better.
That helped it out.
It's just me!
I have tear machine.
I'm coming.
I'm coming over.
Wait, what?
That charge rifle, too.
Really?
Yeah.
I'm gonna... I'm gonna push.
Whoa.
How dare you?
Here.
over there so far I think I think they have scope they have
two snipers yeah they do you must have
okay oh wait that's a window nice shot nice shot thank you
whoa they didn't scan me I'm ready to go whenever do we have
gun yeah I have a gun I have a gun
Waiting for the scan.
Oh, inside.
On me?
Here.
16.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Thank you.
Crack, crack, crack, crack.
Crack, crack.
Look out on you.
Oh my god.
Sorry.
I'm buying.
Crack.
Nice.
I have to heal.
Thank you.
oh nice
last guy last guy nice nice easy i'm glad did you did you
just watch him run past you like i didn't see he when she
told me i was like what the fight he's in front of you i
didn't see him
I wonder what's in the center now.
Now that there's no armor.
We have a...
I need hemlock.
Hemlock!
Okay.
Okay, I need re.
I need re.
Okay, re.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How about P20?
No.
Okay.
Absolutely not.
No.
Okay.
Uh, no, not that.
R-E-R-E, where are you?
Oh, I need that.
Okay, I have...
I have poor badly.
If you want one, tell me.
Two, two, what better?
I need...
I need zero.
I need a bat.
Yeah, and here, one more.
If I have 30, 30, let me know.
Okay.
like so poor with my actually no i have a good guns but i
don't want to use these guns okay every time every time when
i'm i'm gonna give you a shoe i always miss um i always give
it to utah wingman wait wait wait okay let's get wingman
okay landslide um be careful landslide is loaded okay i'm
not scared i'm rev all right do you want the wingman or no
what happened used to be so good at wingman wow what
happened okay okay okay what happened okay why don't you why
don't you use this okay fine okay okay i'll use it i'll show
you how it's done okay okay i still need
I have my favorite gun.
I need.
I still need RE.
I haven't found an RE.
RE.
Okay.
Oh, if you have RE.
Oh, here, here, R.
Nice.
Maybe.
Okay.
Here.
I dropped.
Nice.
I dropped so many things.
Okay, nice.
This mine now.
Wait, I'm gonna...
I know.
I think I dropped a light mag.
I have a key.
Oh, are we going to go?
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, let's go to vault.
Let's just gear up.
Did I have a light mag?
Yeah, I did.
Come over.
Alright.
I'm coming over.
Wait, the wingman doesn't have a digi anymore?
The fuck is this?
Really?
Wait.
Oh.
Oh, there's people!
Oh, no!
Please!
Come here!
I'm giving it up!
Let's give it a try, get it, stay!
Okay, okay, okay, I'm leaving!
Run fast, run, fast, run fast, run fast.
Run fast.
I'm gonna use my earth?
Yeah, yeah, right there.
Please, I just got my wingman.
Let me at least use it one time.
Yeah, push, push, push, push.
What the fuck?!
I'm so sad.
What?
I'm... I'm actually so sad.
Oh my god!
I'm gonna get to use my wing on!
Why did the iron hit me?
He didn't loot my body!
My wingman is still there!
I-I-I would kill...
I would kill him!
Okay?
I have the god loadout!
Are you fucking kidding me?
Dude, you have...
Oh!
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
Are you fucking?
What was this guy?
How can he call me?
No!
Dude, what?
I didn't...
I lost my...
No!
i can't believe it i couldn't i couldn't even use it that's
the worst part i don't even get to use it you have hammer
points and you have big man how really really good but nice
dinner you have no chance use this unfortunately oh my god
oh such a bad timing oh my god
i can't believe it i can't holy shit That was so unlucky.
Bro, fuck that team for still waning in there.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
That was actually crazy.
Crazy.
Go go go go go go Oh my god
No way there's no way we can't get champion We can't get one
more We can we can we can we just got fucked over Don't stop
leaving One team one team we will kill this one and we got
champion Okay, okay, okay, you get champion land here two
team two teams careful two team yes oh my god what happened
what happened goodbye everybody oh nice nice nice okay what
happened look at what's going on right now i'm okay i'm okay
it's fine i i have to keep on believing
Don't stop.
Have a liquid gun here.
You're broken?
I'm broken.
Are you broken?
Okay.
That team that fucking crouched next to that cave?
That is so bullshit.
Oh, stop shooting me.
Wow, wow, wow.
I'm okay.
I don't see one.
I don't see anyone.
They're triple taking.
Where's the second team?
Where the fuck are you?
Don't stop.
Over there.
One guy there.
Where's there?
Here, here.
On my ping.
Anybody close?
They come up.
Wait, I thought there were two.
I don't know another team.
Maybe they went to epic center.
Maybe, yeah.
Do you have loot?
No.
Oh wait, I do.
I have gun.
Okay, do you want to fight?
Wait, is that a window?
I can't tell.
That's a window.
I can't tell!
It's so far!
I don't have a scope!
Okay, I can go up.
Let's do it.
Are we gonna go?
Yes.
Okay.
If we kill them, we win, right?
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
One, two here, two here, two here, two here.
I think I'm gonna die.
What are you doing?
Because they're gonna be me.
Why are you by yourself?
Okay, no, I'm gonna die first, I guess!
Oh, did I die?
I'm gonna die!
We splurged alone.
So I think...
I think maybe we run.
I think...
There's another team behind us!
Uto hide Uto hide
Just hide They're right here Don't let them get to you Oh
now they show up No They know What the fuck I have leave
they just showed up behind us where where did they come from
from behind us oh there was another team I see yeah the
first team that um okay they're on with us and they're on oh
my god how unlucky are we
You're so unlucky.
Oh my god.
So unfortunate.
Okay, this time, this game.
This is it.
I believe.
There's no way.
Three times in a row, unlucky?
Yes, there's no way.
There's no way.
Three times.
Jump,
jump...
I play GB.
Ooh.
Yeah, we have...
We have...
Don't fight.
Oh!
Smart, smart.
This is it.
There's no way!
Three times in a row, no!
We're stronger now.
Yes!
There's...
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
This is it.
Okay.
We're always lucky on countdown.
Yay!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Countdown we've always been lucky.
We always win the fights on countdown.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We have one.
Maybe two teams this time.
Okay, I'm going inside here, yeah.
Yeah, me too.
I'll go right side.
Okay, I'll go left side.
Yeah.
I'll go right I got gun I got gun too I got oh my god I got
really good gun I'm gonna fight I have I'm a really good gun
too okay I will take hi I will take our our yeah they're
over here I'm gonna I'm one of you yeah with those on the
Who took it flank?
We can fight.
This is it.
Over there.
Okay.
Nice.
They're charged rifle, they have shit guns!
36?
Okay.
Their guns are shit!
Oh fuck, okay.
Whoa, dude, careful.
Are you sure?
Are you?
Are you sure it's okay?
Are you sure?
I don't feel okay anymore.
He's so low.
Yeah.
Oh, they're all so low.
They're all low.
No, no, no.
Not this.
No, my first laugh.
What's going on?
You know, I think we got Swapster.
You know, The server is cursed.
The server is cursed.
Ditto.
Pick us another server.
This is a cursed server.
Curse server.
I see.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We go find another server.
Which one?
Ditto.
Surprise us.
You are...
You're server?
My server?
Okay.
What...
All right.
Use my server.
Okay.
Which one?
I will join.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You join me.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You join me.
But don't come here.
Join me.
I can't.
All right.
Thank you.
I want you.
This is it.
All right, here we go.
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright, this is it.
We're not cursed.
We can't be cursed anymore.
We need to be cursed.
This changes everything.
Oh my god, there's so little people in her ring.
What the fuck?
Where are you guys?
15 people.
Why is there 15 people?
It's still primetime ring.
Every hour is prime time.
What time is this now?
It's like 11.43.
Game of time.
Yeah, gamers don't sleep.
Guys, gamers do not sleep.
And because gamers do not sleep, every hour is prime time.
I see.
Yeah, yeah.
Every hour people play rank.
Yeah.
There's no such thing as downtime.
The season literally came out two days ago.
People will still be grinding.
So fast.
Did I wish you were a rookie?
So why are you on his face?
It's my fault.
You're too good.
Too many people.
people grinded rank
this is gonna it's gonna be different now
ah fuck okay no don't worry it'll be different it's not that
different it'll be different it'll be so different trust
same spot Countdown.
We never lose countdown except last game.
No, we never lose.
Yeah.
I was lagging.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now you're gonna be lagging even more, but yeah.
One team, one team.
Oh yeah, above us.
Yeah.
They have burn hall, burn hall and what?
Arc chain?
Yeah.
They're landing far.
We can land close.
I land here.
Okay.
whoops one guy near me but i can okay i'm gonna go kill him
okay you're gonna go kill him yeah what if you don't kill
him nice cake nice you want us to come over over there i'm
gonna crap the bat real fast.
I'm going to head from... I'm heading this side.
I'm going right side.
Whoa!
Careful.
Don't die.
I'm coming over here.
Are they pushing you or no?
No, not yet.
Okay.
They're still inside.
I'm looking.
I'm looking for you.
They're pushing!
you okay we're coming over we're coming over whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa kill not one not one nice nice nice only two only
two let me know they're resting they're resting okay okay go
go go go
nice one what last one last one last one Look, we never lose
countdown!
Wow!
Easy peasy!
We never lose countdown!
I told you!
They always, um, push JP.
Why?
Because you're big and fat.
They're like, ooh.
Nice.
They're like, look at you, so juicy.
Yeah.
Uh, Skyhook, I hear.
You want your cape?
Are you gonna go through it?
Yeah, let's go through.
Okay.
They have nothing.
Oh, they only looted one area.
Can you open that for me?
It's all.
Yeah, I'll go scout.
I'll scout.
Yeah, okay, you go scout.
Never lose countdown.
Okay, I will use Spitfire.
I'm trying to figure out where they are I don't see them I
don't know they finished Oh, Tommy Okay
Yeah, yeah, I did it behind No, that's fine, fuck Okay, I'm
backing out, backing out, backing out Okay, okay, okay,
yeah, did it You can, okay, you only need to Never mind,
cover us, cover us
100 on Fuck, okay.
Oh my god.
Okay
Fuck I'm low Oh, I'm dead.
No No, I got it
You got like, you got beams so fast.
I did beam because I'm fat.
Okay.
Wait, why you not give me?
Wait, wait, wait.
I know.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna play conduit.
You play Rev.
This is it.
This is the comp.
Why?
I believe in you.
No, I believe in you.
I believe in you, Enye.
I believe in you.
You're so good at Rev.
I don't even quite live.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I believe in you so hard.
Okay, okay, okay.
You can do this.
This is it.
I swear.
Your rev is going to be so hot.
Okay.
Wait, Uto, no!
Uto!
No!
Eto, Eto, Eto.
Oh, no!
Okay, it's okay.
We can leave this.
Oh, no.
Wait.
I think she still can connect?
No, I don't think so.
If she can't connect by...
Oh!
Nice, everybody!
Nice, nice, nice.
It'll be different, I swear.
I
believe.
Okay.
For the first time, I'll jump.
We'll do here.
Trust.
Wait, is it one?
Three?
3?
Okay, I'm landing here.
That is way too many.
Wait, we're contested.
What the fuck?
They come with us.
Yeah, yeah, they contested us.
You're by yourself, you're by yourself.
I don't have any gun.
Fuck.
Come to us, jump to us, jump to us.
I can cue you.
You're fine, you're fine, you're fine.
Oh, the fuck.
I don't have anything.
I cracked one.
Nice one.
I cracked the other.
Okay, I will go with punch.
Okay.
Flash?
They're scared of pushing right now.
What the fuck?
We can back up.
Back up.
I have a gun.
You have a gun?
Okay, okay.
Then we can fight this.
I want to just back up.
Okay.
They don't have...
Yeah, just...
They should not have...
They don't have enough, like, heals to fight us.
Because I cracked them, like, three times.
Yeah, okay, cracked it again.
Wait.
I might be able to crack them again.
Yeah, I'll give you...
They have costing.
I'll give you.
Yeah, but they should have heals, because I cracked them so
many times.
No way they found, like, enough shield cells.
Are they still inside?
Yeah.
Are they?
No.
Oh, they left, yeah, bitch.
What?
Alright, let's loot.
Let's loot.
Okay.
Stupid.
Okay, okay.
Let's go loot there.
That's right.
This is what happens when I have...
30 ping.
It's like, I...
Or 60 ping.
Ooh!
all right they finish shooting each other okay oh i'm gonna
go with you ditto no one no one with me yeah no one it's not
like double light oh right my hair light light light
magazine oh nice okay enemy yeah okay all right Yeah, yeah,
he's so so close.
So close.
What really?
Where?
On my left on my left here or behind if you follow me I'm
looking I can't one so I got you.
Okay, let me We can push this guy.
He's by himself.
I'll cover you guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah His teammates are so far.
His teammates are really far You guys push him you guys push
him I'll cover I'll cover where they're coming They're
coming!
They're coming!
Come back!
The teammates are here!
Teammies are here!
Ditto!
Oh no!
Flesh!
Mad Maggie won!
Okay.
Okay, I'm looking.
I'm covering.
Careful, Ditto.
Okay.
I can cover from outside here.
I don't have- I don't have- I don't fail.
Oh, okay.
That's bad.
Jump to me.
I can cue you.
I have cells so you can jump to me.
Oh, he's so low.
He jumped to me.
Jump to me.
You're low.
You guys don't have heals.
I have a... I have a... I have a...
Oh, I have to heal.
We're all really poor in heals right now.
No cell.
Bro, no cell here.
I dropped two for you.
You're getting...
I have Q and three.
Oh, he's so...
They're all so low.
Oh, I can't give you the cue.
There's a guy right here.
Oh, no, Ditto, your spider's out.
Ditto, no!
Oh, he's so lazy!
Leave, leave, leave, leave, leave, leave, leave, leave,
leave, leave, leave.
That's three people!
That's...
That was three people!
You're crazy!
Oh, I don't have any...
A magazine!
Oh my god, you're insane.
You try to...
You try to win.
No, he's...
Oh my god, Uto is like so poor right now.
Here.
She's sorry.
They come, they come, they come, they come.
Are you fucking...
Oh my god!
They're redeployed!
Holy shit.
We don't have another redeployed though.
Oh, and I dropped my Phoenix kit for you too.
I can't even craft you because they're chasing us.
Okay, there's only one thing I can do.
And it's this.
Boom.
I don't know if it'll hit.
Okay, the best, okay.
Oh, I mean, I mean, me, me, me, me.
Are you dead slide?
Ah, dead slide.
Go, don't live for us!
Live!
Oh, wait, no, don't come to me.
No!
I said live.
I said...
No, I got dead slide again.
Jesus Christ.
I don't know.
I said live.
What happened to living?
You can save us, right?
I don't know.
This doesn't look very hopeful right now.
I literally have not a lot of resources.
Okay.
You can do it.
Alright.
You can't do it.
You think they're gonna camp me?
Let's find out.
Whoa.
Maybe they are.
I think they are still close to us.
Okay.
Alright, it's either I do this or I die, so...
Oh, here we go.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
First step, first step, first step.
Well, this is my last heal.
I know, I forgot.
What?
How did you forgot?
You said footsteps!
So I panicked!
I was like, I heard shit!
I heard something!
Yeah.
Yeah, and then I freaked out.
They're gone.
Alright.
Oh, nice signage.
One.
Better than nothing?
That's true.
Alright.
Okay, this is up here.
Okay, look how far.
Oh my god, I think we're gonna die.
We're gonna die.
We're gonna die in zone.
Let me, we are not, we are not.
Believe, okay, okay.
We will not die in zone.
We will not.
We want, we want.
Look how far the zone is, what do you mean?
It's okay.
I'm a plus fighter.
You're, you're rapid.
I have a squad.
Oh
That that makes me worry even more because you said I'm
pathfinding Why Oh, you guys better hurry zone okay okay oh
no oh no i feel like we we are gonna get champion in this oh
no i feel like somebody's gonna camp us right at this edge
right i can feel it i feel that one team just waiting at the
edge no no i don't feel it I feel it, I feel it in my bones
right now.
I can smell it too.
I feel it right now.
Okay.
We will see.
Okay, I'm seeing.
I'm seeing.
No, they're finding each other that...
They have no time for us.
Maybe we can get into that building.
Alright.
Let's go.
I swear to God if...
I swear to guy.
This has been...
This has been a very scuffed game.
Oh, we got...
We got inside the lane.
Oh my god.
One team, one team so close.
Okay, I'm trying to grab...
Hammer point!
One more point!
Okay, I don't think I should bring it to Hammer point.
You should get it.
I don't help.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Okay, I'll be taking it first.
Yeah, yeah, just take it, hold on to it.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
I'm going to you.
There's so many people fighting around us, I'm so scared.
Oh!
I'm gonna craft.
Nice, nice.
I'll craft too.
We have craft.
You can!
You can?
There we go.
How can you carve it?
You carved banner once.
No, each machine is one.
Oh, really?
Yeah, yeah.
It's not one whole game.
Wait, you didn't know?
I don't know.
You didn't try to craft more?
I didn't try to carve more.
You only did one.
Maybe this is why we didn't.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Maybe this is why we didn't start getting killed.
Yeah, yeah, he's solo.
Come on, feed us.
Feed us.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Okay, okay.
I cracked him.
Yes, guy.
He's cracked.
Okay, I'm going.
Go, go, go.
There I cracked him.
Please kill him.
Okay, go, go.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
I know why.
Is that one?
No, no, there is.
Only one.
Only one here.
Oh, no, it's full team.
It's full team.
No, yeah, it's a full team.
It's a full team.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I thought like, um, Levernance.
I'll watch Levernance.
But you down one.
What happened?
I don't know how to jump.
I don't know.
I'm just laying.
There was a full team behind us that jumped after you.
Really?
I didn't think that.
Yeah.
Oh man.
Can I craft anything?
I have to find another one.
No, there's no other one.
The only one is here.
Do you have a cell?
No.
Oh, wait.
Let me use this.
It's important.
It's so important.
You are gonna get us champion right?
Alright, I'm gonna leave.
Wait, that was so weird!
What?
I didn't need that battery.
not need it okay all right here we go all right this is
going to be awkward guys I don't know I don't think we're
gonna get it's okay it's okay we can't do it talking if you
believe just don't stop believing don't stop like you said
you They don't see you.
Don't see you.
Don't stop believing.
Oh my
god.
Why did they turn around?
Where did you come from?
okay oh my god what the fuck okay i feel like past finder i
feel like that game that game we just played i i don't know
that i didn't think we were gonna win okay let's communicate
okay okay okay communicate yes if you tell me go i go if you
tell me yeah yeah yeah okay okay okay i'm gonna use the
patchy one right now
i i know why oh okay i know because um i have 200 being okay
i will pay more safe more
safe champion basement until champion
I haven't I haven't ate it on breakfast yet and it's um 3 p
.m.
now It's so fast so fast it's 3 p.m.
now 5 p.m.
now yo so yes yes yes hungry no no no no eat No champion, no
food.
No sleep.
Okay, I will play button.
Okay.
I'm back.
Who needs to eat?
um there's no one need to eat good
only play only winners eat until we win the game okay only
winners eat yeah Uto Uto said that she was hungry but um she
didn't need to eat oh eat and play Yes, yes.
Eat and play.
That's why we have two hands.
Two.
Don't you have two hands too?
Yeah, but I'm not hungry.
I already ate.
I can play until we got the champion.
Yo yo, we got this.
We got this.
This is it.
I believe!
We just need to find the perfect comp!
Just keep believing!
Just believe!
Believing!
Just keep believing!
if I can fly.
Me too.
But you can fly because you're a bird.
Yeah, exactly.
I can't believe.
I don't even need to believe.
I know it's a fact.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
You're right.
Your turn.
Okay, okay, okay.
Go here.
This is our champion spot.
Our champion spot.
I agree.
I believe.
There's no way come with us.
Oh my God.
We are champions.
There's no one gonna steal our loot.
I hope so.
I'm double checking.
I'm scared.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Oh, thank god, okay.
I thought I was scared you'll lie to me.
No.
I'm not...
Oh my god.
I'm not lying.
Alright, here we go.
Oh yeah, remember when you said you heard people over here?
Remember that?
Do you remember?
That's sad.
wasn't that a lie no that's true where did the person go i
think um they they left the game oh they left the game they
tc where was his box oh maybe they're cheater and they were
trying to kill you and they got banned oh yeah yeah yeah
where was the box
You didn't...
Where was the box?
Because you couldn't find it.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I couldn't find it.
Yeah, it just disappeared.
Yes.
Wow, so spooky.
I need repeater.
Why?
Okay, I got...
Name is this an R9.
R9 again.
I have a hemlock in R9, but I want a repeaters.
Okay, I'm good.
I need hemlock.
Oh, not hemlock.
Uh, 30-30.
Okay.
Where am I?
Oh, I want that hemlock.
Uh, 30-30.
Okay.
Oh, I'm gonna grab the wall actually.
Prowler?
Prowler SMG.
Prowler.
Nice one.
Where is the 30-30?
Okay, I will ping you if I fall on it.
30-30.
Does anyone need bats?
I have six.
I have two.
Here.
Uh, whoops, that's not it.
I dropped two?
Four bats.
Okay, I got it.
If anyone, um...
Um... I have... I want... I want scope.
Scope.
Yeah.
Oh, I have scope, but it's my scope.
Oh, let me see.
Yeah, okay.
You found one, see me.
I just wanted you guys... you to know.
Okay.
Alright, Uto.
Uto, you're gonna kill... 10 people, okay?
10 people?
10 people.
Yes, yes.
You killed 10 people.
And then we win champion.
That's it.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I believe in you.
If you don't kill 10 people, I need midship.
I'll report you.
Okay, okay.
I'll report you for creeping my game.
Oh my gosh.
You don't want me to report you.
There's more of us here.
A lot.
I don't need to get it.
Hi.
Okay, each kill you get?
Each kill?
You get?
You can have one bite of food.
Really?
Like, yay!
What is this game?
It's like a dog.
Like, you know, you're training a dog?
No!
Don't you like it though?
I would die.
How can she?
Just make a paint.
What?
Don't you want to bite?
Oh my god.
Here's a scope.
It's called positive reinforcement.
Oh my god.
I'm rewarding her.
She gets to eat.
What?
What was that?
I heard a slide.
In here.
Kiss, kiss, kiss, kiss, kiss.
I'm gonna go.
I'm pushing.
Okay.
I'm right behind you.
Go, it's a go.
Okay.
Go.
Wait, where did you?
Oh, here, I love here, I love here.
Oh, here?
Okay.
Maybe this guy?
See?
Scan?
No.
Where the fuck did they go?
I heard, I heard, I heard something.
I heard something.
Oh, here.
Okay, but remember last time you heard something?
I really heard something!
Okay, okay, okay, with the scan.
With the scan.
Yeah, you heard something.
There's people here.
Oh, in front of me, in front of me, in front of me.
Go, go, go, go.
Wow!
Here in front, two teams, two teams, two teams.
What the fuck is going on?
Okay, I got one.
Yeah.
Are they finding each other?
Hey.
Here they are.
There's like a team in that building.
Okay.
I will scan.
Why?
They move so fast.
Oh wait.
Wow!
That's a different team.
I'm just gonna...
I'm still like holding on to like...
Yeah.
I remember you heard something, Ditto.
Over there, over there, over there.
Holyo, Holyo.
Cake!
Yeah.
I'm helping you.
Nice.
High ground, they're high ground now.
I'm gonna come to you.
There's people in front, there's people here.
Okay, I'm gonna scan next building.
No one in next building.
Train tracks.
I see people in train.
Not chain, uh, steamer, steamer building.
Okay.
Steamer building.
Whoa!
What the fuck is wrong with you?
What the fuck?
Yeah, he fucked me up.
Oh.
All right, I need a heal.
Is that a sniper?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uh, sniper and uh, 30, 30.
They're not...
This team really wants to kill me.
I'm coming over to you guys.
Behind?
Yeah, behind.
Okay, I'm going to... I'm going to you, Ditto.
Okay.
I'm good, I'm good.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Behind the two... two teams.
Behind me.
What a fight with my aim.
There's like a...
I'm gonna...
They're like all so far, they're so far.
Yeah.
Everybody's just running away from each other.
So we can't really do anything.
Yeah.
They keep running.
They're all so scared.
Come on!
Leto needs to eat!
She needs to get a kill!
Hungry!
Okay.
There is...
They're all just poking each other.
They're not fighting at all.
Wait, wait.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Fight, fight, fight.
Maybe we can go to that party.
Yeah, they're fighting here too.
They're fighting here.
Okay.
What?
Pushing up.
Okay.
I'm just seeing my earth.
They're really far, Ditto.
You didn't tell me.
I went there.
So far.
And I went up to...
There was you!
Here, here, here!
I'm using my arm!
He's so long!
Yeah, we're okay.
Kind of long.
I'm gonna go get anchor.
Here, here, in front of me, in front of me.
I thirsted, I thirsted.
Okay, Ditto, you're by yourself.
I'm coming over, I'm coming over.
I'm here, I'm here.
Oh, she got you?
Okay.
I got the bat.
I thirsted him for you?
I need.
then another team another team behind me they are where yeah
I see him I see him yeah careful careful though almost came
here oh my gosh wait behind me see I 100 where is it 100 oh
sorry I got one I got one here okay I got to you I will go
to you yeah maybe he's he's batting he's Okay.
Oh no, I got scan.
I got a thing.
Oh!
Fuck.
Oh shit!
Okay, here.
Yeah, but there it is.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
You might have a bullet.
Oh
my god.
You might have a bullet.
Oh my god.
Wait!
It was two T's and they shot at me!
It was two T's.
They both shot at me.
Oh my god.
Okay, Uto, how many kills did you get, Uto?
Okay.
How many kills Uto did you get?
How many kills?
Zero.
Uh, no bite.
No bite.
How many kills did I get?
Oh, I got zero too, so...
Only Ditto can eat Why?
Wait, did you get one kill?
I get one knock.
Oh, one knock?
No bite.
I get one kill.
Okay, you can have one bite.
One bite.
Can I stack my bites?
Yeah, yeah.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no stacking.
No stacking.
It's it's training.
We're all training
We're here to train Oh my god, what what a chain what what
chain Champion we're training for champion.
Oh, I see Yeah, I forget I almost forgot you always forgot
that's the reason why we haven't stopped.
What do you mean?
I have to order some food first.
We can do this.
I believe in this.
What are you going to eat, Uza?
What are you going to eat?
Kills.
She's going to eat kills.
Okay.
Why do we land here?
Yeah, I'm landing here.
Do we have team?
Oh, we have team.
On team, yeah.
Yeah, we have team.
That's Mirage.
Okay.
that is all fake that's okay but i hear i hear people oh no
no it's leo mirage yes did you say that's stupid who said
that yeah that's stupid oh my god there's a lot of people
there's a lot of people there's a lot of people there's a
lot of people there's a lot of people there's a lot of
people i'm scared i'm I got the gap.
I got...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
We're so healthy.
This is two teams.
Two teams?
Two, two, two.
I have a sentinel.
Okay.
Oh, I'm good.
Okay, I'm good.
Do you have light?
Oh, I hear them.
They're still fighting.
Wow, wow, wow.
Oh, I got scanned?
Oh, knock, knock.
I hear knocks.
Nice.
Above us?
Yeah.
I'm gonna heal.
Okay, where are you?
Where are you?
I am here.
Oh, shit.
They're shooting her from high ground.
They're still fighting.
I'm going to wait a bit.
They thirsted.
I got scanned.
Can you push?
I cracked one.
Cracked Bloodhound.
Careful, careful, the other, um, the condo might drop on
you.
Where's Bunhall?
I don't know, I didn't, I don't know where he ran, too.
Oh, my God, it's...
Oh, my God, it fucked up everything.
I thirsted?
Okay, I got thirst, I got thirst.
Okay.
Drop, drop to me, drop to me.
Wait, wait, wait.
Careful.
One down.
I can...
What the fuck?
I'm thirsty No, no, no No, no Okay, okay Cover me, cover me,
cover me Okay, okay Where's the cover?
Where's the cover?
Did I not open?
Did I not open it?
Yeah, cover I don't know where They are Where are you?
No, I hear it.
Two, it's two, it's two.
You're here.
Running.
Running, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna go, Rez.
I don't know.
You get one bite!
Uto!
Yeah, I have one.
I also have one bite.
Oh my god!
Hungry!
You had to have one bite.
One bite.
What other food you want?
one five three
okay but that grapple was was funny i i fucked i fucked my
gabo two times and the same place at the same place all
right i don't know where he ran to he like ulted and
disappeared wherever he is i think they're they're gonna go
Yeah, I think so too.
We can loot then.
Oh yeah.
We won.
Okay.
There's a...
I got...
Okay.
We did it!
Yay!
We'll run double heavy.
Nice.
I will just hemlock and rot.
Yeah, I'm using hemlock prowler.
How far?
Oh, it's not that far, the zone.
It's not that far, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Look how he's there.
Oh, let me find Repeater.
Oh, they're reviving us, guys!
They are?
Oh, I'm too lazy.
They can live.
Let's go.
Yay!
Oh, this is looted.
Okay.
Just load it.
Yeah.
I heard going up the armor.
Evo.
Oh yeah, Uta's still a white armor.
So I was trying to find a 30.
Yay!
Oh, thank you.
You guys need bats?
I have four.
I have two.
Look at how many...
Oh, here.
I'll give one.
Thank you.
I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna open this crate.
Oh, more bats.
But I should have it.
Yeah, yeah, there's two extra here.
And two back two.
I have me a scope.
Oh, yeah, I find a scope.
Um, which score?
Uh, two, three, or four.
Okay, okay.
Oh my god, hammer point!
Fuck, uh, I'm gonna grab it.
Light mag, light mag.
Yeah.
Okay.
Did you just get 20-20?
Yeah, but I need to try to find a...
Okay.
R-E.
R-E?
Yeah, I just wanted to put it on my gun first.
I need R-E.
Okay.
R-E.
Yeah.
Okay.
This is it.
We believe.
We need RE.
Please.
Okay, let's go to Zone.
Let's just slowly head to Zone.
Alright.
Tito.
Where is Zone going to end?
Um, Skyhook.
Okay, let's go to Skyhook.
Okay, okay.
Oh my god, I see your surroundings.
Oh, that's not good.
I believe.
We need to keep believing.
Oh, one team land there.
Define to Skyhook.
I mean, we could just walk, honestly.
Okay.
I don't think we need to redeploy.
We can just walk over.
I don't see them.
I bet Ditto you're going to run into a three-man and die.
Oh, I can't.
Okay.
Uto, Uto.
I mean, go in front.
Go in front.
No, no, no.
Uto goes in front.
Uto defends us.
I want to...
Is that...
I want that.
What?
You see someone?
No.
Armor, armor.
Oh, no, we don't need it.
We don't need it.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
We're strong.
Okay, I believe you.
I, yeah, believe in me.
If we die, it's not my fault.
It's not my fault if we die.
Believe.
Gotta believe.
We just gotta keep believing.
The reason why we keep dying is because we stop believing.
I believe.
I, maybe I think I have never believed it at first.
You didn't believe?
What's wrong?
No, I'm leaving.
Okay, okay, okay.
Is this why we're still playing?
I feel like that's a pro team.
The Horizon Octane.
Because like...
Because usually pro teams...
Or like not pro team, but like...
Pred teams.
Pred teams, they put...
They put streamer mode.
Okay.
I see.
Did you get... I'll e.
Here.
I got it.
I found one.
majority of streamers put streamer mode on because they
don't want to get sniped i mean which is obvious whoa wait
oh my god there's a there's a lot wait wait you okay you
can't you can't have it me okay but i have re oh Is that...
Is...
Is Eva 8 good?
Yeah, Eva 8 is broken.
Ooh.
Okay.
Someone needs to get it, because it's actually strong.
Yeah, Eva 8 very strong.
Oh no!
Um, wait.
I think it's... It's taken.
What?
No, no, it's right here.
No.
It's in the box, right here.
There's a death box that I need.
Oh, this box?
Yeah.
Okay.
No one took it.
Oh my god.
Um...
First shot.
Okay, believe!
Why are you not believing, Tito?
Okay, believe, believe.
Okay, I'm believing.
Okay, good.
I'm used to flying now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Keep believing!
Wait, they're resing.
Another team here too.
I think we can wait a little bit.
Yeah.
Team here.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, they're...
Someone's pushing them.
Crack the horizon?
Oh, so low!
Very low!
Nice!
Push?
Yeah, push, push, push.
Oh my god.
Oh, we got kill.
We got the kill.
Careful, careful.
I don't think we...
Another team.
Another team?
Okay, okay.
Careful, I don't have Q.
I don't have Q.
Another team, another team.
Okay.
I have Q.
Maybe come to me.
Come to me.
Come to me, Ditto.
There's so much left.
Okay, okay.
Okay, go back.
Go back, fall back, because there's a...
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can go on the outside, I feel like.
Actually, Lincoln, where do we go?
Inside the building, inside the building.
Yeah, yeah.
Do you want to go outside?
I got the bag first.
We can stay here.
We can go here.
Stay here for now.
I don't want to go there because I feel like everybody
should shoot us there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's one team have duo, only duo.
Okay.
I'm gonna charge my uh.
All right.
Whoa, careful.
Wow.
I'm gonna check our back.
There might be someone in the tunnel.
I'm double checking.
Save, save.
Oh, so close.
Whoa!
They have Kraber.
I don't have Q.
Good luck.
It's okay.
I'm good.
But I don't have Med Kit.
I have Med Kit.
Here.
Okay.
I got you.
We gotta figure out where to go.
we got a portal maybe portal portal to here
where do they go wait where are they going oh wait they're
jumping far yeah I think we don't need portal we can just
walk oh my god there's it's getting scary I still have no
repeating I still have no repeating
Oh, there it is.
I found one.
Found a repeater.
We need to get to...
But, um...
It's not inside the lane.
We could go here, too.
Wait, that's not a zone, I'm sorry.
No, no, sorry, here.
Yeah.
Are outskirts?
Do you want to try out?
Or...
I feel like here is better.
Okay.
There's no one here.
Yeah, there's no one here.
Okay.
And there's people...
I'm trying to look right now.
I can't see them.
Oh, here?
Octane over.
I don't have an angle.
Are you going there?
Okay.
Ah.
He saw me!
Alright, I'm gonna get across.
Oh my god, I wish I had a sniper stock.
Can I get...
One team at market.
So much harder with no sniper stock.
Can we go there?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm safe here too.
Okay.
I'll stay here for now for a cross.
I don't know where the other team is.
Okay.
Is that right?
He's not behind.
Oh, the high ground team.
I think we have to go.
Shit!
Oh my god!
Okay,
I think we should go under, right?
Okay.
Do we portal?
For it?
Maybe?
I don't have portal.
Like Uto, Uto has portal.
Oh, Uto, can you?
Can you...
Maybe portal under?
Portal under?
I believe in you.
Fuck that.
Whoever made that fucking...
Cover.
Let it flash.
We got her.
Is it safe?
Safe, safe.
We got the goal!
Yes!
Careful, careful.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna back.
Okay.
Oh, Krabber over here.
Yeah.
Safe here too.
Safe here.
Okay.
Yeah.
If we need to, we can.
They come here.
Least.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Kill, kill, kill.
This is safe too.
Where I am?
Okay.
There's sniper stock in there?
Can you check?
Can you check if sniper stock?
Sniper?
Sniper stock.
I don't know.
Okay.
You check real fast?
Yeah, yeah.
I need sniper stock.
This.
Um, no, no, no, no.
Don't have it.
I think it's like a team here and then above us.
The Kraver team.
Yeah.
Kraver here, Kraver.
Oh, no, no.
We killed the Kraver team.
Yeah, there's no Kraver team.
Okay.
the team above us the team above us has i mean i can alt i
can i can alt the center where is the center let's move here
yeah i have to alt this oh my god
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh Why is that a team?
A lot of them.
Yeah, on the ramp.
They're on the ramp.
And then the other team's above us.
Whoa!
I really can't hear.
Don't stop believing.
You can't stop believing!
I have four arms though.
We can't stop!
Where are you?
Oh, wait there, here, here, here.
Okay, go on.
Shoot it, shoot it, shoot it, shoot it, shoot it!
Woo!
Oh my god!
Oh, sorry.
I got- I got not- Oh, I'm fucked.
They're fighting each other.
You're fighting each other?
Oh, no!
Live!
Oh, don't!
I'll let you know, I'll let you know.
I'll let you know.
What?
That's one guy!
That's one
guy!
It's one guy!
I'm blocking him!
It's blocking!
We did it!
A token E!
Oh my god!
We did it!
We ended!
I'm so proud of you!
Alright, alright.
Oh my god, that was really fun Chie-chies, guys Thank you
for playing with me Thank you, good night, good night Good
night, everybody Have a nice, have nice lunch, dinner okay
okay yeah thank you for playing thank you for playing i had
so much fun yeah i'll see you guys bye bye bye oh my god
well that was that was such a i did not expect to have such
a long session it just was really fun it was it was very
very fun i lot i enjoyed playing it with playing it with
Ditto.
I always enjoy playing with them.
Yes, please check them out.
They've always been good friends of mine and always enjoy
playing Apex with both of them.
But yes, I saw so many memberships.
I'm so sorry I didn't thank all of you guys while I was
playing.
I'm so sorry.
Usually like when I'm in a collab, I try to like focus on
the collab, like just interacting with people.
So I am so sorry.
But thank you everybody.
I saw so many 50 gifted Chips.
It was crazy.
Beats, thank you for the 50.
Get the ships.
Thank you.
And thank you all for the super chats, everybody.
I hope you guys had a lot of fun.
It was a very long session.
So it was also a very long bod.
So I hope you guys had fun watching.
I really did enjoy playing with both of them.
Tomorrow is also another collab with Yusun with Inside the
Back Rooms.
So yeah, I'm going to enjoy playing that as well.
Thank you, everybody.
I am going to pass out now.
I'm so tired.
Okay, I didn't tell you guys, but I woke up at like five in
the morning and I've been awake since.
I've been awake.
So, yeah, my sleep schedule still hasn't been fixed yet, but
we had a fun time watching.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up
and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
buddy bye guys bye